welcome to this comprehensive sequel
tutorial course designed for beginners
and also those looking to prepare for
technical interviews this course was
developed by the team at Jovian who have
created many popular courses for our
channel in this course we'll cover the
basics of relational databases and SQL
including setting up MySQL inserting
data and working with aggregation
grouping and pagination and SQL queries
the course also covers Advanced topics
such as combining tables using joins
executing SQL queries using Python and
SQL Alchemy and solving technical
interview questions by the end of the
course you'll have the knowledge and
confidence to excel in SQL is it SQL or
SQL well it doesn't really matter
because you need to learn it no matter
what it's called hello and welcome to
this tutorial on SQL where you will
learn the basics of the structured query
language which is used to fetch data
from almost every database in the world
no matter what you're doing in data
science you will need to learn these
skill and this will be part of your
daily job and this course guides you
step by step and you can follow along
with everything that we do in this
course to learn the basics of SQL and
even learn how to crack interview
questions from the top companies in the
world
so I hope you enjoyed this course leave
a comment and subscribe to our Channel
if you'd like to join more of these
courses and let's get started the topic
for today is relational databases and
the structured query language or SQL and
here's what we're going to talk about
today
first we will talk about some of the use
cases and the design of relational
databases and SQL what they are and why
they are used
we will see how to set up a database
locally using the MySQL server
we will create modify and delete
databases and database tables we'll see
how to do that
we learn about the data types in SQL and
some constraints like primary key
foreign key Etc
we will look at crud operations you will
see this term a lot in relation to
databases so create read update and
delete operations on data stored in
tables and then we'll also look at how
data can be exported and imported
from relational databases
this is part one of two lessons on SQL
so the next week will be an advanced
lesson where we will look at
aggregations we look at joins we look at
indexes and we will also see how to use
how to use Jupiter to get data out of a
SQL database and how to work with it in
Python so maybe how to do some analysis
and how to do some visualization
but today we are going to work in a more
traditional setting where we are going
to use some
commonly used software like a MySQL
server for working with SQL databases
now we learn about relational databases
in SQL by working through this problem
this is a hypothetical scenario that
we've set up and we'll try and
understand in the context of this
problem why we want to use a regulation
database and how SQL is helpful
so classic Models Incorporated is a
manufacturer of manufacturer of small
scale models of cars motorcycles planes
ships trains Etc
and products manufactured by classic
models are sold in toy and gift stores
around the world so this is what some of
their products look like they are small
scan models of
various types of vehicles
and classic models has offices around
the world with dozens of employees
and these are primarily sales offices so
the customers of classic models are
typically toy or Gift Stores and each
customer typically has a designated
sales representative uh in the same
region who's also an employee of classic
models
and they interact with that sales
representative directly
then customers typically Place orders
requesting several products in different
quantities and then they pay for
multiple orders at once via checks so
this is typically how a business works
you have you manufacture some products
and then you have offices and then you
sell your products to people and you
have transactions with them and you have
employees involved who are involved in
managing these relationships and
managing the offices that you run right
now for an international organization
like this it is important to record all
of this information all of the
activities in a single central place
right so your task is to create a
database some sort of a system where you
can record and manage all of this above
information so where do we have our
offices who works at these different
offices who are our customers how who is
the sales representative for every
customer what kind of orders are
customer placing and what what are the
payments from them what do the payments
from them look like so we want to record
and manage all of this information in a
database in a central location and this
database will also be used for
day-to-day operations for example adding
new customers placing orders recording
payments hiring employees and things
like that and also just querying
information and getting analytics about
how the business is doing
so while there are many ways of storing
data on a computer for example we could
put this into a bunch of text files we
could maybe open notepad create a few
files and put in all this information
there but looking it up is going to be
very difficult we could use Json files
we could use CSV files we could put
maybe have a CSV file for customers one
for products one for employees we could
use spreadsheets things like Excel which
a lot of businesses use but spreadsheets
become a bit Limited in functionality as
you deal with really large data sets and
as you want to do some
Advanced forms of querying and also as
you want to integrate this with these
systems with other systems for example
you want to create forms for customers
to sign up you want to create order
forms you want to create a bunch of
different things connecting forms with
spreadsheets and writing custom business
logic can be a bit tricky
so this is where a relational database
comes into picture a relational database
is a data storage system
typically which has the following
properties so the first thing about a
relational database is that data is
stored in tables
so each kind of entity that we are
concerned with you have a table for it
for example you have a table for
customers
and this is a snapshot of some data
stored in a relational database so you
have a table for customers and each
customer has a customer ID they have a
first name they have a last name they
have a date created which means the date
at which or the exact time at which that
customer
was added to your database and then you
have a bunch of information maybe where
they live etc etc right
so that's one important piece that data
stored in tables
second each table has a set of columns
as you can see here each stable has a
set of columns and each column is used
to store a specific type of data for
example customer ID is going to be a
number and it's in fact going to be a
unique identifier for the customer first
name and last name is their first and
last name and then date created is going
to store the date or the time exact time
when they join and so on
next data in the tables is stored as
rows so each row of this data after this
header row represents a customer and
sometimes these rows are also called
records so data stored using rows within
database tables
next table support crud operations on
rows which means create read update and
delete so you can add new rows into the
table that's the create operation
you can delete rows from the table
you can delete rows from the table that
is the delete operation you can get data
out of the table let's say you want to
figure out which customers you have in
the United States then you can query
that you can just type out some code and
you will get back that information and
you can update information because if a
customer changes their address or their
phone number or their email you should
be able to change that then one
important piece so a lot of databases
support this but one important piece is
relations between tables so tables can
be connected to other tables using
relationship constraints for example
you have offices and you have employees
we can say in the employees table that
an employee works at a particular office
so we can make a relationship between an
employee record and an office record and
there can be one-to-one relationships
there can be one too many many-to-one
relationships and we will talk about
these in more detail when we talk about
joins but at the moment the just the
fact that you can link records across
tables is an important piece to
understand
then relational databases typically
allow you to retrieve data from the
database using the structured query
language or SQL which is what we will
learn today
and these databases can either be hosted
locally on your computer
or more commonly these are hosted
somewhere on the cloud for distributed
access for example for
classic models it's possible that they
have set up a database on the cloud and
all the employees from all the different
offices use this database
through some browser-based application
maybe they have Farms or maybe they have
some kind of access-based system where
different employees have different
permissions and they use this database
but everybody's ultimately making
changes or getting information out of
the same database right and this is how
most modern applications work for
example on Jovian we have a relational
database sitting somewhere on the cloud
and all of your account information is
on in the relational database and when
you open your profile we get data out of
that relational database and we show it
to you okay
so that's relational databases the
important pieces are that data stored in
tables a set of columns each column has
a specific type
and then tables can be conducted using
relationships and the data is queried
using SQL or the structured query
language
now when
you are setting up a relational database
which you most likely won't have to do
because in most cases whatever
Corporation you work with or whatever
client you work with in a project they
will already have a database but when
you're setting up a database it is
common to First create an entity
relationship diagram or it's called an
ERD to describe all the tables within a
data within the database and the
relations between them
so ERD this is what an ERD looks like an
entity relationship diagram and they can
be created using drawing tools like
lucidchart so typically this is
something an image like this is what you
might be given when you join a company
they may give you an image like this and
they would tell you that this is what
our data model looks like or this is
what our database looks like
and sometimes you may have multiple
ersds because different teams or
different or orgs or different
departments when this in the same
company may have their own separate
database and sometimes you may have data
duplicated across different databases
and so on but let's just take a look at
this ERD and understand what it
represents
so the first thing you will notice is we
have these boxes we have this one box
called payments we have this called
offices
we have employees customers product
clients products orders and audits so
each box in an entity relationship
diagram shows you a table
okay so for example offices is a table
and then inside each box this is the
list of columns in the table
now the ERD does not contain any actual
data it is sort of a blueprint for the
database on what tables it contains and
what are the fields within each table
and how the tables are connected so the
office is stable for example will
contain an office code and you will see
that this is you can see a key icon here
if I zoom in a little bit
so this is a key icon so that is simply
to indicate that
the office score is a unique identifier
for the office and this is also called a
primary key
so the office code is the unique
identifier or the ID just as on Jovian
you have a unique ID which is your
username so similarly office code is a
unique ID and then the office is based
in a certain city it has a certain phone
number it has a certain address address
line one address line two a state
country postal code territory and maybe
even a location a geo location for
plotting on a map
okay
and different ways in which erds are
created may or may not contain this
additional information for example here
what this blue square represents is that
this is a required detail if it is
filled in and if it is not filled in
then that means that this is optional so
you can have address line 2 may not be
present for some offices because it's
enough to summarize the address in one
line but yeah you may not always have
these details and this ERD does not
contain information about the types of
data you can probably guess office code
would probably be either a string or a
number a city would probably be a string
phone would be a string all of these
would mostly be strings
then you have employees so for employees
we have an employee number so that's the
primary key and I think that is going to
be a number then there is a last name
first name extension so this is probably
employees work at an office so at the
office what is the extension to reach
this person via phone you have an email
for the employee and interestingly there
is this reports to feed so most
employees in most companies report to
other employees of the company so this
reports to is some sort of a link from
employees to
the same table of employees so reports
to would probably contain an employee
number of another employee in the
company
then you have job title and then you
have something called office code so
office code again is going to be the
office code of the office where the
employee works
so you can already start to see these
relationships employees work at an
office so there is an office code in
employee and that office code should
match with the office code of a
particular office and then you can do
interesting things like find all the
employees who work at a particular
office or maybe given an employee find
the full phone number which is the phone
number of the office combined with the
extension for this employee and
similarly you will now see other
relationships you have customers so
customers have all this information and
then in customers you have the sales rep
employee number so this is going to be
a reference from the customers table to
the employee table
the employee number should match up with
an existing employee then you have
payments done by customers so customers
pay by check so you can see here there's
a customer number which is a reference
field
then customers place order so there is a
table where we are recording orders
where we have an order number order date
some information about the order some
comments and there is a customer number
indicating which customer has placed the
order
but of course an order can contain a lot
of information so
you can place you can have many products
that you would have or that you can
include in an order so we have a table
for products like product code product
name product code is the unique ID
product name product vendor Etc
and product code there is also a product
line which itself is another table so
you may have four or five product lines
and in each product line let's say the
product lines are cars motorcycles
ships Etc remember
this company creates
small scale models of vehicles so
product lines could be the different
kinds of vehicles
and the products could be then
individual vehicles or individual actual
products that they create and then there
is this order details so an order can
potentially have many products that were
ordered so in order details
so for one order you may have several
records in order details and you may
have the order number you may have the
product code and then you may have the
quantity ordered so let's say in order
number one
the customer customer number 10 creates
order number one and in order number one
they request product number five product
number six product number seven
and each with a different quantity so
order details is used to track all that
information okay so this is how all of
this fits together you have tables with
columns and then you have relationships
between tables and
uh understanding and entity relationship
diagram is the first step towards
understanding what a database contains
and all these
symbols have certain meaning which we
will talk about the next time when we
talk about joins in one to many and many
to one relationships okay
now there are several relationship there
are several relational database
software packages and some of them are
free and some of them are open source
While others are paid and proprietary
and the most common ones are these MySQL
is an open source and free option they
also have a paid option but the free
option does the job for most people then
you have postgres you have sqlite you
have Microsoft SQL Server Maria DB
Oracle IBM db2 so some of these are
proprietary
so for this tutorial we will use MySQL a
free and open source relational database
software
now the concepts that we learned today
will be applicable across any of these
but the syntax the actual code that you
need to write May differ so just keep
that in mind and just try to understand
the the key Concepts
and we'll talk about how you can look up
the differences in code Maybe by
comparing let's say with the postgres
database and primarily it's simply a
matter of looking it up on the
documentation or finding a stack
Overflow answer over time once you join
a company most companies will only use
one type of database so over time you
will become comfortable in the flavor or
in the kind of in the software package
that your company uses and the
variations in SQL in the SQL language
that software package requires but your
skills should be transferable across
different
SQL variants
Okay so we've been saying SQL a lot or
SQL what is it so SQL stands for
structured query language and it is a
programming language for interacting
with relational databases now we've set
up this database somewhere
and now we need to put data into it and
then we need to get data out of it maybe
we need to change some data within it
for doing all of those things you use
the SQL programming language
and unlike general purpose programming
languages like python Java C plus Etc
SQL has a very limited syntax and a very
specific use case the specific use case
is to interact with a relational
database it's you cannot use SQL for
data visualization for example you
cannot use SQL for building software
building
web applications you cannot use SQL for
creating scripts you cannot use SQL for
machine learning it's that is not the
purpose of SQL the purpose of SQL is to
put data into tables into relational
database tables and get data out of
relational database tables and make
changes so it's all about working with a
database without a database there is no
SQL
and this is what its syntax looks like
so this is all one single SQL statement
it's split across multiple lines but you
will see at the end there is a semicolon
indicating the end so here what we're
saying and SQL is a very readable
language so here what we are saying is
select top three so we want to select
the top three
products so we want to select product ID
from the sales table
and you wanna
select the product name and you want to
select the total quantity of products
sold
from the table sales and then you want
to do a join so again there is some
joining merging involved and then you're
doing some kind of a grouping and then
you're doing some kind of an order by
and then you're doing some kind of a sum
and then you are sorting it in
descending order so you have all of
these things that you're putting
together there are many pieces that are
coming together here and we will learn
some of these pieces this week and some
of this pieces next week but by the end
of these two weeks you will be able to
understand exactly what this statement
does and you will be able to write
statements like it and it's not too
difficult it's just that you have to
understand what each of these parts
represents okay and that's what we will
go over step by step
so you type in a SQL query and you send
it to the database and then the database
gives you a result so typically it is
some sort of a
subset of the table like here we are
selecting a certain set of rows so that
so the database is given just three rows
of data and it has given just three
columns of data the actual table or
tables that this information has been
drawn from can contain several thousands
or millions of rows and can contain
several columns as well so you don't
always want to see all the data
sometimes you just want to see the data
that you are concerned with and
sometimes you want also want to
summarize data by taking the sum Etc
okay
now a quick note on SQL statements there
are three types of statements in SQL one
is called the data definition language
so there are three parts to setting up a
database first or using a database first
is to set it up which means
taking the entity relationship diagram
and converting it into an actual
database with actual tables
in your local copy of the software or
somewhere in the cloud okay so here we
are concerned with
generating a table generating a database
or modifying the structure of a table
making connections between tables that
is called the data definition language
or that is one of the parts of SQL then
you have the data control language the
control language is primarily about
managing user access rights so for any
database system you have a way to assign
permissions to users so you can create
users and then you can give users
permissions and some users may have read
permission some users may have write
permissions sometimes you can also
control information per table so you can
control who can write to let's say the
employees table so only the
administrator should be able to create
new employees but maybe all employees
should be allowed to create new
customers right so you have all these
rules and that is also something that
you can do with SQL not something that
we will cover extensively because
this is not something that you will have
to deal with maybe the database
administrator will already set this up
for you but the most important thing
that we will deal with is the data
manipulation language which talks about
which is the most frequently used subset
of SQL and it is used for searching data
so if you have a database getting some
data out inserting data into a database
updating a database updating some
information that's already there and
deleting data right so the crowd
operations create read update and delete
those are the operations covered in the
data manipulation language now you don't
need to really worry about these terms
ddl DCL DML you never have to deal with
them but it's just that you have three
there are three ways in which we use SQL
statements to create a databases and set
up the structure to manage permissions
and most importantly to actually do
crowd operations on the data
and before we start writing some SQL
code a quick note
on the syntax so SQL syntax is case
insensitive which means that you can
type statements in uppercase lowercase
or a mixture of both like here we have
select top three sales dot product ID
you can write select in lower case you
can maybe write S as a
a s and lowercase and E in uppercase l
in lower case it won't matter same is
true with all the column names most of
the time in most SQL distributions they
are case invariant so you can use
uppercase lowercase whatever seems more
convenient to you okay
and
one thing that you will notice is at
certain places we will use these back
ticks or back codes so this is called a
back code especially for database names
and column names and table names now
these are optional so wherever you see
this character it is completely optional
the reason it's there is
primarily just to differentiate between
the SQL syntax and keywords and actual
table names and and such can we see this
in just a moment
then SQL statements can span over
multiple lines so you can write three
four five ten lines in a sec in a SQL
statement and you have to end it with a
semicolon that's the important piece if
you don't put in a semicolon then your
statement may not get executed or the
system is still keep waiting for some
output
and then finally all the statements that
we are going to execute in today's
tutorial
can be executed on MySQL now this MySQL
can be running
on your computer it can be running
somewhere on the server and it can be
accessed in two ways which is the
command line or the workbench and we
look at both in just a moment okay
now the SQL syntax as I mentioned for
every relational database software
package is slightly different so if
you're using postgres or you're using a
Microsoft SQL server or Oracle it's
going to be slightly different so just
check the official documentation of your
database for details what we will learn
is the kind of operations that you can
do on database tables and the specific
syntax is just a matter of looking it up
all right so with that let us set up
MySQL server locally now you don't need
to do this right now but whenever you're
following along with this notebook a
definitely set it up locally on your
computer and the download takes a while
that's why I'm recommending you don't do
it right now but do set it up locally on
your computer and experiment with all of
this code all of the things that we are
doing
to see the effect that these statements
have okay
so you can download you need two things
you need to set up the MySQL server
so here's the MySQL server you can go to
dev.mysql.com download slash MySQL
and select your operating system in my
case it's Mac OS and then select the
kind of archive you want to download you
can see that this is a 415 MB file so it
takes a while to download now I've
already done the download so I don't
need to do this again but if you're on
Linux for instance then you may want to
either download a tar archive or
if you do download a tar archive then
you may have to follow some additional
instructions as well if you're on
Windows I think you should be able to
download yeah you should be able to
download
a zip archive that you can directly
open up an Exe on
I think on Lin on Ubuntu you should be
able to download some kind of
installable bundle so whatever operating
system you're using you should be able
to download one version
now we just need the MySQL server we
don't need anything more than that but
and the MySQL server will set up a
database for us and allow us to create
tables within databases and query
databases and so on and you can run it
and we are going to run it locally but
it can just as well be hosted on a
server as well right so but we are going
to run it locally
to interact with the MySQL server one
way is to use the
command line interface so now in my case
I have installed it on Mac so I'm just
going to open up a terminal
and let me zoom in this terminal a
little bit
yeah so now I have opened up a terminal
and when I installed MySQL after
downloading
it created this folder slash USR slash
local slash MySQL
so it created this folder and you can
see this folder here if I do LS
and where did I find this well I just
looked it up where does MySQL get
installed on Mac OS and I got this
response where it's in slash USR slash
local MySQL in your case in your
operating system this location may be
different this may be in C program files
or this may be in somewhere else on
Ubuntu so you would have to look this up
but in this folder slash user slash
local MySQL there is a folder called bin
so I'm just going to type slash bin here
and then there is a folder called let me
just check LS on bin so you have a lot
of things inside bin but the one we
should be concerned with is MySQL the
command line interface
so I'm just going to run slash user
slash local slash bin slash
MySQL so now this is a command line tool
that I'm going to run
okay and to run this the first thing
that you will need to do is you will
need to provide a username and by
default when you install MySQL it will
have the username root
and then you also need to provide a
password when you're installing so when
you download this file and then you're
set doing going through the installation
steps it will ask you to set a root
username and a root password in my case
I set my root username to root that was
the default option and I did set a
password as well so here is how you
specify the username and the password so
you say
you give the path to the MySQL binary or
the MySQL command line tool and you
specify using minus U which user is
trying to access it and root was the
default user that they had that it had
set up and you specify minus p and it
will prompt you for a password so I'm
just going to type in the password Here
yeah so I've just typed in the password
now and now what has happened is MySQL
was already running on my computer after
I installed it
but now I have logged in into this
database server which is running on my
computer as the user root okay and if
MySQL is not already running on your
computer then you will not be able to
log in so if you get an error here that
MySQL is not running then you would have
to go and check in my case what happens
is
on Mac OS
yeah so on Mac OS it creates a it
creates this MySQL option in settings so
if I go to my system preferences it
creates this option
MySQL and here I can actually stop and
start my server here I can also just set
up some configuration about where MySQL
is going to store all of its data right
so by default MySQL will start up
whenever my computer starts up so I can
set all these configurations right so
the MySQL is is a application that is
always running on my computer and it
starts up when the computer starts up it
shuts down when the computer shuts down
you will have to set it up separately on
Linux or on Windows and when you do
install it normally it all of this
should be taken care of automatically
okay so make sure that MySQL server is
running and find the path to this MySQL
binary which is on Ubuntu also I think
it's user local MySQL bin MySQL on
Windows it might be slightly different
and then login into MySQL so login into
the server as the root user and once
you've logged it into the root user you
will see a welcome message and you will
see the version of the MySQL server
that's running on my computer
and now I can start interacting with it
on this prompt so as you see here it
says MySQL and then I can start typing
SQL commands here
okay so that's one way to interact with
this database and I am currently running
on my local machine but
if there was a MySQL server that was
running somewhere on the cloud and I had
the URL to that server so I could also
put in the URL there's a way to specify
the URL when running this tool and you
can use this tool to connect to any
mySQL database anywhere in the world as
long as it is publicly accessible and
you know the username and password for
it okay so if you have the URL to a to
mySQL server you can log in into that
MySQL server as well like for example I
from my computer can log in into the
Jovian production MySQL server and maybe
make changes to my username and things
like that okay
all right so that is one way to access
MySQL that is one way we will look at
today
but another way to access MySQL is using
the MySQL workbench so there is another
installation link that we've included
here this is to download the workbench
which is basically this graphical user
interface
so you can download the workbench this
is a again 100 MB download and the
workbench also
let me open it up the workbench also
connects to a MySQL server so when you
log in for the first time you will see
that it automatically detects that you
have a MySQL server running locally but
if you want you can also connect to
something that is running somewhere on
the cloud so again if you have the IP
address or if you have the host name if
you have what port it is running at if
you have the username and password for a
database server running on the cloud
then you can get those details and
connect to that database so typically in
a company setting what will happen is
the team that you're working with or the
person that you're reporting you that
you're reporting to will tell you that
here is where our database lives so you
should set this IP for our database you
should set this port you should use this
username we've created a username for
you you should set this password
and then you should then you can click
connect or you can even test the
connection first and then you can click
connect and then you will automatically
get connected to the company database
and then you can work on the company
database or your teams database and get
data out of it or write data into it do
queries on it
in our case today we are going to just
use the local installation that we have
of MySQL so I'm just going to connect
MySQL workbench to the local
installation
all right so this is what it looks like
and the kind of queries that you type
here for example
I can type a query
so for example I can type a query here
on the MySQL command line tool show
databases
and I can type the same query here in
the MySQL workbench
show databases
and then I can run it so this is the way
to run it
or you can also press Ctrl enter or
command enter to run it and it shows the
same information so here it shows the
information classic models information
schema MySQL performance schema Etc
and here it shows the same information
as a table okay so it's just a little
nicer here everything is shown as text
here you can interact with it a little
bit you can click on things and such
so those they are just two different
ways of interacting with the same
underlying database that's running
locally right now and both of these can
also connect to things on the cloud
okay so with that out of the way we can
finally start working with databases
so let us set up a database for classic
models in my case I have already set up
a database let me just remove that
database for now
okay all right so once you are connected
either through the command line or using
the
MySQL workbench to a SQL Server so the
server code again could be running
locally or on the cloud you can start
writing SQL statements so the first
thing that you want to do as soon as
you're connected to a database server is
to just list the databases that are
present on the server so I can just type
show databases
and put a semicolon
and that is going to show me the list of
databases that are present on the server
so by default right now I've just set up
this MySQL server on my computer so
these are all some of the default
databases that MySQL already has so we
definitely don't want to disturb any of
these switches information schema MySQL
performance schema and sys okay but once
you create more databases you will start
to see those databases showing up here
so that's the first thing show database
is going to show you a list of databases
then the next thing you can do is
create you can create databases so here
is how you create a database you type
create database and then you type the
database name so I'm going to create a
database
classic models
and let me just run the statement so
I've typed create I've typed database
and I've typed the name of the database
classic models
and now the database is created and I
can check show
databases
once again
and now you see you have classic models
here as a new database that has been
created
now
in this notebook what you will see is
the statements are typed in uppercase
create databases uppercase and one other
thing you will notice is that all
database names column names table names
all of these are lowercase and they are
indicated with these back ticks this is
called a back tick this is just for
visual separation so that you know that
this is this is a SQL keyword and this
is the name of a column or a database or
a table so this is just for that visual
separation so that when you're going
through this notebook it's clear to you
and you can also run it like this you
can take this code and you can run it
exactly the same way as it is typed here
or you can type it without any of the
back text and just in lower case and
this is also perfectly fine except that
it's a bit difficult to read okay
so now that we've created the the
database we can now show the database as
well
grade and if we try to create it again
MySQL will give us an error so you can
see here we run create database classic
models and it says it can't create a
database because a database already
exists
so we can also specify a condition
to create the database only if it or
doesn't already exist so if we say
create database if not exists classic
models
so this is when we don't know if the if
the if there's already a database with
that name on our server so
then we can create that database if it
does not exist if it does exist then
nothing happens so if we type this
create database if not exists you can
say you can see that it says query okay
one row affected but there was no real
change like if we say just show
databases you can see that we have
classic models information schema MySQL
performance schema and sys so no change
here on the other hand if we had typed
create database if not exist classic
models too
and by the way I'm using the up Arrow
key to cycle back to older commands
so up and down is how you cycle between
older and your commands
so if I type create database if not
exist classic models 2 you will see now
that we have classic models and classic
models too which got created okay
so now we have several databases on our
server
and typically for every project that
you're working on you would create a
database or sometimes every team would
have a database on the database server
so there are many different reasons for
why you may want to have different
databases but for classic models the
company we're just going to create this
one database okay
and when you are connected on a server
and you want to work with a certain
database let's say you want to get data
out of the database you want to add
tables remove tables add rows remove
rows you have to tell which database you
want to use so we can say use classic
models
and once you say that then MySQL is
going to change the database to use or
is going to point to Classic models as
the default database to which all
operations will be applied so let's say
now if we do something like a create
table operation which we'll see now and
then we type the name of a table and the
columns that it has then that table will
get created inside the classic models
database okay so whenever you get
started always make sure that you are
running the use statement to select the
database that you want to operate on
typically MySQL remembers this so you
won't have to do it over and over but
whenever you log in it's always a good
idea to just run use classic models
all right so that's how you use a
database and one last thing I want to
cover is how to delete a database to
delete a database you just type drop so
we have currently classic models classic
models two information schema Etc so I'm
just going to do drop database
classic models too
and a semicolon
and now if we check show databases
you can see now we no longer have
classic models too that database was
deleted I can also go ahead and drop
classic models and then you will see
that now we no longer have classic
models either
okay now be careful about drop because
as soon as you run the drop statement
the data will be deleted permanently
there is no trash and there is no
warning there is no confirmation and
typically your company will not give you
access to drop databases for good reason
but regardless you should be very very
careful about running the drop database
command okay
so as an exercise you can now just try
creating deleting using some databases
using the commands that we've covered
and also try and figure out how to
rename a database so now you can try and
look it up on the MySQL documentation or
just by searching online how to rename a
database okay next just before we move
forward let's just recreate the database
classic models because we are now going
to create some tables with it so I'm
just going to run create database if not
exist classic models and use classic
models
all right so now our database is created
and we can start using it okay let's now
talk about how we can work with tables
now
we remember the entity relationship
diagram that we created for the classic
models company
we can now start adding some tables
based on the ERD and
there are a few statements there are a
few four or five statements that we need
to understand to work with tables
the first one is to list the tables in a
database now once you select a database
using the use command you can list the
tables in a database using the show
table statement
so if we go here and we say use classic
models
and then we say show tables
you can see that currently it says empty
set because we've just created the
classic models database so it does not
have any tables but we know that it is
empty so we know that much
then to create a table
we can use the create table statement
and here's what the create table
statement looks like you type create
table and then you type the name of the
table and then you have
this you open these brackets or these
parentheses and then you type the name
of a column and then you type the data
type of the column and then below it you
also have some constraints about the
tables or some other information that
you want to specify about the table so I
just want to show you an example of what
a create table statement looks like so
here is the ERD diagram for the offices
table now for the offices table we have
this office code which is the unique
identifier for each office or this is
also called the primary key in SQL then
we have all this information City phone
number address line one this is all
required and then we have address line
two State this is optional information
then we have country postal code
territory this is required and then we
have office location which is optional
so this is what the create table
statement for office
for offices looks like so we say create
table offices and again you can skip
these backticks these are just for
convenience sometimes column names can
have spaces so to handle things like
spaces we have backticks but here you
can just use you can just use it to
visually identify what is a SQL
statement and what is a name of a
database or a column or a table so we
say create table and then we type create
table with the name offices and then we
open up this bracket and we say office
code so that is the name name of the
first column
and office code is going to be aware
care so this is the data type and we'll
talk about the data types and so it is
going to be a
character list or a variable number of
characters that's what it means where
care of up to size 10. so office code
can be one one character two character
three character up to 10 characters
then we are specifying here a constraint
that it is not null which means that it
cannot be empty then we have City again
which is a wirecare 50 so it can be a
string where care simply corresponds to
a string essentially it can be string up
to 50 characters long again not null
then it will have a phone number again
it will be a string not null it will
have an address line it will have a
second address line and this time
it will this can be null so we don't
necessarily need to have a second
address line it can have a state again
this information can be null it can have
a country
this should be should we not null a
postal code a territory okay so
territory would typically be I think it
would probably be country or maybe the
territory which the office operates in
okay so we'll see an example of this and
finally at the end of specifying all the
columns we are also specifying this
constraint or this additional piece of
information that we want office code to
be the primary key for this column so
what this does
is the primary key constraint uniquely
identifies each record in the table so
the office code value in the office code
column will uniquely identify each
office and what that means is that
you can only have
one row with a specific office code you
cannot have two offices or two rows of
data with the same office code and it
also cannot be null and that's why we
have specified not null here already
okay
and a table can have only one primary
key constraint so you you can select
multiple columns you can say that the
primary key is office code comma City
although in this case it will not make
sense sometimes it does so you can
select multiple columns as the primary
key so a primary key can consist of
multiple columns but you should only
have the statement written once so if
you want to select office code comma
City so both of those together as a
primary key then you you should write
primary key office code comma City and
not primary key office code and in
another line primary key City okay
that's a more special case that doesn't
really happen so for now let's just take
this code
and let us run it
here
in our MySQL command line
okay and we run it and as soon as we run
it it says query okay zero rows affected
so whenever you see okay that means that
it has had the intended effect so now if
we run show tables again
you will see now that there is one table
in classic models the table is called
offices
okay now talking about
the data types you see wire care if most
of these are bad care but
there are several supported data types
in SQL so here are some of them you can
have numeric data you can specify that a
column is a bit bit means it's going to
be a zero or one or a tiny integer I
think that is going to be one byte which
means it can take values from 0 to 64.
a small integer I think that would be
four bytes
a normal integer I think that would be a
small integer would be two bytes a
normal integer would be four bytes a big
integer would be eight bytes etcetera so
the differences between all of this is
simply in the
range of values that they can hold bit
Can Only Hold zero to one big end can
probably hold from minus 2 billion to 2
billion
so depending on what range you think
that your numbers can take you can
choose the right data type and if you're
unsure just go with int or begin just to
be safe
a lot of companies have had to change
from int to begin once they hit maybe a
billion users so not many such companies
but that is what that was a real problem
they probably didn't expect to hit a
billion users and they had to change
from in to begin for user IDs
numeric user IDs
then you have the decimal data type so
if you're sure about how many digits of
decimal you want then you can use the
decimal data type as well or you can
also use a numeric data type
I think this allows you to put in any
kind of data something that you would
have to look up you can use the float
data type to work with floating Point
numbers here you can specify how many
digits of precision you want and then
you have the real data type as well so
again not all of these data types are
supported by all SQL software because
every all companies have implemented
their own version and they have their
own optimizations so you would have to
look up whichever package you're using
like for MySQL you would have to look up
which of these numeric types MySQL
supports
and then there are date related types so
you typically have a date time and then
a date time or a time stamp
data type for working with dates then
you have the character types so you can
have a character which is a single
character or you can also specify when
creating a cad data type how many what
is going to be the exact length so if
you have if you are sure that you will
always have five characters in a column
you use care or care five so just as we
have written wirecare 50 you can write
five and then you always have to put in
five characters or you can put in where
care and wear care means that you can
put up to 50 characters so if you type
wirecare 50 that means you can put up to
50 characters
and then you have the text data type
which is typically used for very large
strings so if you want unbounded if you
don't want a limit on the number of
characters then you can use the text
data type
now what is the benefit of
not using text maybe using wire care it
is efficiency when you can specify the
number of characters your data can take
based on that the database
server can perform some optimizations to
make queries faster but if you want to
use the text data type then you are
giving up on some performance
then you have these Unicode characters
which is a special case of characters
you can also store some binary data and
then you can also store something called
a blob which is like a large binary
object so you can store XML Json and
these are more specialized types that
are not supported by all SQL servers but
numeric date and characters or strings
are the most common data types okay
so that was data types and next Once a
table is created you can also check
once the table is created you can also
check
the table that the table is created
using show tables here we've typed show
tables and we were able to see the table
and if you want to get information about
what columns the table contains you can
use the describe
command so let's type describe
and let's type the name of the table the
name of the table is offices
and when you type describe offices you
can see here these are all the fields
office code city phone address line
State country postal code territory all
of these are where care some of these
are nullable which means some of these
can be null and some of these cannot
should not be null and office code is
the primary key okay so still this is
still information about the table this
is not information in the table it's
just information about all the columns
of the table
and you can also specify default values
for some of these columns let's say you
want to specify a default value of phone
number to the phone number of the
headquarters so that there is always a
number listed on your website so you
could have specified that the way to
specify your default is to say
let's say phone number not null and
you could instead say here phone number
default
and then you can give the phone number
that you want to have as the default
phone number okay maybe plus one
that's the default phone number so that
will be the default phone number that
will be put in for any Row in the data
okay
so now we've created a table we have
seen what its Fields look like we have
seen that that table got created
let's put some actual data into the
table so to insert data into the table
we use the insert into statement so
here's how the insert into statement
works you type insert
into and then you type the name of the
table so the name of the table is
offices and then you type the columns
the names of the columns that you want
to specify so I want to provide the
office code I want to provide the city I
want to provide the phone I want to
provide the address line one and maybe I
won't provide address line 2 because I
don't have that information I am not
going to provide state I'm going to
provide country I'm going to provide
postal code and I'm going to provide
territory okay so we say insert into
offices and then we give the list of the
column names that we are going to supply
and then we say values and then we
provide the values for these column
names so okay now I'm going to insert
create this new office with the office
code AAA
and it is going to be in Bengaluru
and the phone number is going to be plus
9 1
that and then the address line is just
going to be
well let's just put it as
1 mg Road
and then we have a postal code let's
just put that as
five six
zero zero one
oh we also have to specify the country
so the country is India
and finally let us put in a territory
here so I guess that this will probably
serve the territory of Asia
right so let's then put the semicolon
here so what have we done insert into
name of the table list of the columns
that we want to supply information for
put in then type values then give a list
of the actual values for each of these
columns and then we can hit enter and
you can see query okay one row affected
and now this is going to insert the data
into the table
how do you get data out of a table well
the way you get data out of a table is
by typing select you can type select
and then after typing select you type
which columns you want so let's say I
just want to get the office code
and I want I want to get the city
from
the name of the table the table name is
offices
and then I put in a semicolon
yeah sorry no no brackets here so you
type select and then you type the name
of the columns that you want to select
and then you say from offices okay and
you can see that it starts to get a
little bit confusing now because
everything is written in lower case and
that's why we often write
the column names in lower case and we
write the
SQL commands in uppercase
okay and sometimes we also put backticks
just to make it super clear
and especially if you have names in if
we have spaces and column names okay so
select office code comma City from
offices so now it is giving us the
office code and it is giving us the city
for all the rows of data in the database
in the
table offices so we have inserted one
row we inserted a row with all this
information and then we viewed it using
select now if we had inserted multiple
rows we would be looking at the data for
multiple
rows of data how do you insert multiple
rows inserting multiple rows is the same
as inserting one row you just say insert
into offices and then names of columns
and then type values and then you give
one set of values then you give a comma
and you give the second set of values
and so on so let's insert multiple rows
I'm going to copy insert into offices
and then I have a bunch of rows of data
here
so I'm going to copy all those rows of
data
okay it's going to be a bit difficult to
copy this all right let's just copy it
this way now this is a lot of code there
so I am going to instead of using the
MySQL command line which I can do I can
just paste the command paste on the
command line here I'm just going to show
it to you on the workbench
okay so I'm just going to type it here
into the workbench
you can always just click new query and
oh sorry yeah you can just always click
this new query here and then just type
it
so here now we have insert into offices
we have all these columns that we want
to insert and then the values we have on
we have one one set of values two set of
values three four five six all the way
up to seven so we are inserting seven
values and at the end you will notice a
semicolon here at the end of the last
statement and we can run this command
and now we get a success result here
oh we need to select a database first so
let me cut this and let me say use
classic models
and let me run that so that has been
selected the database is selected then
let us paste it back
okay now we have insert into offices and
now we run insert into offices and you
can see that it it executed successfully
so now we have inserted into offices and
I can create a new query here
I can
yeah so I can now remove this and I can
type
select
and if I want all the columns I just
type star so select star from offices
and then I run it
and that is going to now show this data
in this tabular format okay so now you
can see that we have all these offices
San Francisco Boston NYC Paris Tokyo
Sydney London Bengaluru and this is the
same information that we had shown that
we had inputted here that is also
available so
through the command line and through the
workbench we are connecting to the same
database and we can run these commands
in either place and I can type it here
as well select star from offices so now
when I say star it is going to select
all the columns
and here's what that looks like it's a
bit messed up the output because it's
trying to display it all on one line but
if I zoom out a little bit you should be
able to see the output
yeah
so you can see the output now when I do
select start from offices it is giving
me the same table that I am able to see
here on the workbench
okay
so that is insert and select
just a quick reminder on how these work
so you can say insert into and then
provide the table name provide the names
of the columns you want to insert
provide the values and then provide
lists of values to insert so list of
rows and if you're providing data for
all the columns then you can skip this
part which is the column names so you
can just say insert into table name
values and then you can give lists of
values and that will work fine too for
example here when we are inserting
offices we are using all the columns
here so I can actually just completely
skip this last thing I can skip this
names of columns and I can just say
insert into offices values and give it
the list of values
then to view the data the simplest way
to view data is using the select
statement so it has the syntax select
column one comma column two comma so on
from table name and you can also view
the data from all the columns using
simply saying select star from table
name
okay so that's how we put data and get
data so now we've covered C and R create
and read and we'll look at update and
delete as well
and here are some exercises for you try
adding some more entries into the
offices table
using just the required column so an
example that we typed out on the MySQL
command line try typing it out yourself
try doing it from the command line try
doing it from the workbench
and see what happens
see what happens if you don't provide a
value for a column marked as not null
okay maybe here if I go back to one of
these and if I try and change this
let's say I changed the office code to
aab and I provide I don't provide a
value for territory which is supposed to
be non-null
let's see what it's going to give us so
it's going to give us an error but you
want to do you want to make these
mistakes and you wanna
understand what kind of Errors you get
like here it says field territory
doesn't have a default value so
look through it and try to break things
and try to become familiar with errors
so that when you encounter them you will
be able to debug them more easily so try
adding an entry with the primary key
matching an existing entry so maybe
let's try that let's try putting in AAA
again and let's just make it Bengaluru
2. and let's just put in
territory Asia here
and let's add back territory here
so you will now see that
okay I probably have
yeah there's probably a syntax
error here
okay I made a syntax error here
somewhere
but if I just try to insert the same
data again like a Bangalore root 2.
you will see that now it says that
there's a duplicate entry AAA for the
key officers.primary and that data is
not inserted okay
so test these out the more you try the
more the better you will understand how
some of these things work and try and
retrieve and display just the city and
phone number information for each office
that has been created so just do a
select statement and try that out too
and that's the first table that we've
created we've put some data into the
table we have looked at the structure of
the table and we've retrieved some data
from the table as well next is the
employee stable so we've created one
table and now we are creating a second
table and we will connect this table to
the first table
and a quick note if you want to first
delete a table then you can use drop
table so if you type drop table that
will delete the table with all its data
like if I type
drop table and then I type Offices here
that's going to delete the offices table
I don't want to do that right now
because I've put some data into it and
you can also have something like this
that if the table exists you can drop it
so if we type drop table if exists
employees
this is not going to make any change
because if I do show tables
there was no employee stable before and
there's no employee stabled now but
whenever you're creating a table you can
always it's a good idea to First maybe
drop the previous table if you're sure
that you don't need the old data if you
want to Fresh
table to be created so you can just drop
the previous table if you if you want
right so that's why we have this
statement here for you as well
so okay let's talk about creating the
table employees so let's copy this code
and here we have an employee number so
that's an integer our first encounter
within teacher
and here we're saying 11 so I think what
we are specifying here is
I I think it might be 11 bytes or 11
digits I'm not sure I think it's going
to be 11 bytes I'd have to look it up
then we have the last name which is a
wire care or a string a first name is a
string extension this is their phone
number extension so they will be at a
certain office and that's why we have
office code here and then we have an
email which is again a wire care of a
hundred and then we have a reports too
so two interesting things here one is
office code so we have now A office code
column and this should ideally contain a
value of a valid office code how are we
going to ensure that we will see and
second reports to and this can be null
so office code should not be null every
employee belongs to an office but
reports to can be null because obviously
there will be somebody in the company
who does not report to anybody
but otherwise reports to and maybe some
people may not have been assigned a
manager or a reporting person so reports
to can be null but reports to should be
somebody's employee number let's say you
have
siddhant and biraj and if barrage
reports to siddhant then reports to in
the entry for biraj
should be the employee code or the
employee number of Siddharth okay how do
we ensure that we look at that then we
have the job title this is just a simple
string
and we are setting here that primary key
is employee number that makes sense we
want to uniquely identify each employee
with a primary key and
this was going to be not null so that's
fine too
and then we have these two in two
statements foreign key so here we are
saying
that reports to the column reports to
references the table employees
and in the table employees it references
employee number
okay that's one and then we have another
foreign key office code so here we are
saying that the tape the column office
code
in this table
references
the column office code from the offices
table
okay so there are two references here
one is a
one is a reference to another table
one is the reference to this table
itself but probably to a different
record so what we are saying through
this or through a foreign key in general
is that we want to ensure that the
office code column contains a value
which matches a value
in the office code column from the
offices
database now from the offices table
right so for every employee there should
be an office code and that office code
should contain
a valid value from the offices table and
that is what the foreign key constraint
ensures and we will test it out in just
a bit
and then similarly we have foreign key
within the same table we want to say
that the reports too for any employee
should be a valid employee number
from the employees table and it can be
the employee number of a different
employee so that is or enforced using a
foreign key a foreign key is simply
you're saying that this number or this
column
has a special property that it refers to
a value from another
table
and there is one important constraint
with foreign key the value that you
reference to must be the primary key in
that table so for example here we are
referencing office code of offices so
office code must be the primary key in
the offices table now again this is not
a criteria that all SQL software or all
relational databases have sometimes they
do sometimes they don't but in general
just to be safe you should always assume
that you should only reference primary
keys okay
so let's try it out let us insert a
value into employees so let's just let
me just grab this
insert into employees the values one
zero zero two so that's the employee
code Murphy Diane x5800 and so this is
what is this employee number last name
first name so Diane
murphy1002 and their extension is 5800
and their email is D Murphy at
classicmodelcars.com then their office
code is
one
and do we have an office code one we do
have an office code one one is San
Francisco so that means they belong to
the San Francisco office
then reports To None So they do not
report to anybody and in fact Diane
Murphy is the president so they're the
boss
so let's run it
oh it says
employees doesn't exist or that's
because I dropped the employees column
I never created it in the first place
all right so let's first create the
employees column A create table
employees let's take this and let us run
it here so now the employees column is
created and then let us insert some data
into the employees column
I am just going to insert this one
person right now
Diane Murphy
and that's it and let me just put a
semicolon here and insert the person so
now if I do select star
from employees
you should be able to see
sorry about the formatting
but you should be able to see this
information about this person Diane
Murphy with the employee number one zero
zero two
as the office code 1 and reports to
nobody
let's add another
employee maybe let us set their
yeah let us set their office code let's
set their employee code to 1002
or 1003
and
let's call it
Daniel
and let's give an invalid office code
here maybe let's give a hundred and
let's see what happens
so here you will see that it cannot add
the child row so this is called a child
so the employee is now called a child of
office because it has a foreign key
constraint and the foreign key
constraint fails you can see that
constraint that this should be a valid
office ID fails and that's why you
cannot add that row okay that's how the
whole thing works
all right so maybe let's add all these
employees and then we will move forward
but to add all these employees there are
going to be some issues because I've
already created an employee with the
primary key one zero zero two so before
that I'm just going to delete the
employee that I've just created
you see right now I have this one
employee Diane Murphy so I'm going to
delete the employee with employee number
uh 102. so I can say this I can say
delete
well actually let's come back to delete
later for now I'm just going to drop the
table into entirely so drop table
employees
okay so now the table employees is gone
if I do show tables once again
and now I can create the table once
again I will go create table employees
and then let us
insert all this data so we have a bunch
of employees here I'm just going to
capture cap copy all of this
and paste this command
if you want to do the insertion here so
maybe let's just do the insertion here
so we're just going to insert all of
these employees how many of these we are
going to insert about 23 employees
using the MySQL workbench and now these
should be created so now if we check
select star
from
employees
you should now be able to see
all the employees that we've created
okay
now here are some exercises for you try
inserting an entry
into employees with an invalid office
code you saw what happened but try it
maybe from the workbench try inserting
an entry into employees with an invalid
value for reports too
okay that is something that we haven't
tried so reports too can either be null
or it must be an existing employees
ID or employees number
and try this try creating a new office
location first and then try adding some
employees to the new location so when
you open a new office first you will
have to add a new office
object or a new office record and then
you will have to add an employee add a
bunch of employees for those office
records and maybe you will have one
office manager and that office manager
will probably report to the president
and then you will have a bunch of
employees at that office and they will
report to that office manager
okay do try out that exercise okay
moving ahead now we have the customers
table so now at the by this point you
are probably getting the idea there is a
primary key there are a bunch of
required columns there are some optional
columns and then there are there is some
there is this foreign key so every
customer has a sales rep optional sales
rep
so you can take this foreign key sales
rep employee number and that should
reference in the employees table some
employee number and you can see here
that sales rep is an integer but it can
be null so I can just copy paste this I
can take this create table if not exist
so this is another way to go about it
create a table only if it not it does
not exist all of these are slightly
different if you try to create a table
without this so if you just say create
table customers if there's already a
table customers it's going to fail if
you drop the table first then it's going
to delete all the data if you say create
table if not exist then if the table
exists it won't do anything if the table
does not exist
it is going to then create the table so
think about what is the right thing you
want to do and based on that use these
drop and not exist and does exist and
play around with them and see what they
do okay
but I'm take I'm going to take this
create table
put it into my workbench
and just execute it and this should
create another table
yeah this should create another another
table customers and on the left if you
just check the schemas tab you should be
able to see all the
tables that are present so now you see
here you may have to refresh it a couple
of times but you have this customers
table you have employees and you have
offices
and when you click on a table you will
also be able to see the information
about that table like on customers you
have customer number customer name last
name first name so this is our MySQL
workbench makes it a little easier for
you you don't have to type a lot of
commands like describe and such you can
just browse the tables that are there
you can also browse the information
about tables you can in fact
even check values within the table I
believe if you just
click this button it is going to
automatically run this select star for
you so if I just click this button here
it's going to show all the employees by
running a select star from classic
from employees right and this is one
other way to write something you will
see often you can also type database
name dot column name or sorry dot table
name and then
put a query so if you're not already set
a default database using the use command
like use classic models you can just put
select star from classic models.employes
so this is database dot table name
okay
so here's an exercise add some customers
to the database
using data from a SQL file so somebody
asked what to can you get data at data
programmatically can you add data which
is already there somewhere else so let
me open up the SQL file and this equal
file contains code for everything that
we are doing today of this classic
models SQL file and in this SQL file you
will find some rows for inserting data
into the customer table so let's find it
let's see so here we have a bunch of
create table statements then you have
these
insert statements for customer for
products
and then you have an insert statement
for offices employees and okay here is
where we have an insert statement for
customers so I'm just going to grab this
this seems like a whole bunch of insert
statements here so these are all the
insert statements for customers I'm just
going to go back to the workbench
and I am going to do a new query
think
not sure
which one it is
never mind I'm just going to edit it
here I'm just going to go to query one
paste this all right so it seems like
there's a lot of insert statements
I'm not sure why they wrote it like this
they could have written it all in a
single insert statement too but in any
case we have 125 customers you can see
here you can see the details of these
customers they are so these are
typically customers are stores remember
Gift Stores and toy stores by
the products from classic
from plastic models so customers are
stores and then each customer has a
point of contact if I go back here
you will see you have a customer name
and then you have a customer number
customer name is the store name contact
last name first name is the information
about who to contact their phone number
Etc
so all that information is captured here
you will also see an employee ID so this
one is probably the employee ID and then
you have
okay so here there's also some kind of a
location data you see sdg geom from text
Etc so you can also put location data
into MySQL that's pretty interesting
so let's run this let's see if this
gives a correct result yeah seems like
it was able to insert data into
the customers table all right so now
we've inserted data for about 120
customers and we should be able to see
that
here in the response
yeah
so you can see we have data for over 100
customers and that's great and some of
them have a sales rep some of them don't
have a sales rep customers also have a
credit limit and such
okay so now when you start getting to
this point where you have a lot of rows
in your database then it may not make
sense to look at all the data at once
that is where you may want to select
some data you may want to query some
data you may want to filter out data
based on a particular condition and that
is where the where clause in the select
statement becomes useful
so you have this where clause
so you have this Clause called where
that you can include after your select
So when you say select star or select
some columns from the employees table
you can say where job title equals sales
rep now if you go back and check the
employees table here
you can see that employees table there
is a job title here and let's say if you
only want to get a list of the sales
reps so we say select star from
employees
where
job title
equals and then whenever you want to put
an actual value for comparison you use
double quotes very important
sales rep okay so select start from
employees where job title sales rep and
maybe I can also select specific columns
so let's say I want I just want to
select the last name
and I want to select the
extension
actually let me just select the office
code
okay so last name first name last name
and office code
from employees where job title is sales
rep
and now it starts to become more useful
so now we know that at office code one
we have Leslie Jennings who is a sales
rep at office code 2 we have Julie
Farrell who's a sales rep at office code
3 we have George wanu who's a sales rep
and so on so the where Clause supports a
bunch of operations where supposed to
equal to which is what we have used here
it supports less than and greater than
so both of these work with
numbers and with strings and with dates
so pretty much all data types with
numbers they expect as expect they work
as expected 3 is greater than 2 and 3 is
less than 5.
which strings they compare the
alphabetical order so a is less than b
and any string that starts with a is is
less than any string that starts with b
and any so let's say a a is less than a
b and you can have this lexicographic or
alphabetical order from A to Z is lower
to higher you can also have less than
equal to or greater than equal to and
you can have not equal to now sum
variations use this less than greater
than some
relational database software use this
not equal to so let's see what MySQL
uses
how about we first try not equal to
okay MySQL seems to support this but you
could also have in some places this kind
of a statement so seems like MySQL
supports both right if I do star here we
can verify if that is the actually the
case
yeah so we are now getting the list of
people who are not sales reps by using
less than greater than or we can also do
are not equal to here
all right
so here's what that looks like you can
also combine expressions in the where
Clause using and and or so let's say you
can say things like
select column one column two comma from
table name where condition 1 and
condition 2 and condition three so for
example if we want to select the sales
rep in San Francisco so what San
Francisco let's first open up offices
and in offices let's check San Francisco
that's office code one so if you want to
get the sales reps in San Francisco so
we say select start from employees where
job title equals sales rep
and
we can put in the additional condition
office code
equals one and again we should put this
in quotes ideally
okay just a single equal to
yeah
so now you see here we have the data for
Leslie Jennings and Leslie Thompson
their extension and their email and both
of them are in office code one which is
San Francisco
so that's how you filter data out like I
can I'm just showing showing you here
it's going to be a little bit bigger
here so that's how you filter data out
from a database table
you use the where clause in where Clause
you can have one of these conditions you
can also have you can also do something
like this you can use in between and
like
and then you also have this option to
negate things so you can also negate a
condition by saying where not condition
that's another thing to just keep in
mind and a where Clause can be used with
select but they can it can also be used
with update and delete statement so we
were talking about delete earlier so
maybe let's check out the delete
statement once and now from this point
on mostly you would just have to look up
how certain statements work
so here we say delete from table name
where condition
now remember we had this one office that
I had inserted initially called
Bengaluru
and this side the office code AAA now if
you want if I want to delete this office
then here's one thing I can do let me go
back here I say delete
from
offices
where
office code
equals
AAA
and that should have deleted
the Bengaluru office
let's see
so you know you can see that we no
longer have the Bengaluru office anymore
because we've just deleted it now here
I've deleted exactly one column but I
can delete multiple columns as well
let's say if I wanted to delete
if I want to fire the sales reps in San
Francisco so then I would do
delete from employees where job title
equals sales rep and office code equals
one right instead of Select star I would
just type delete and then instead of
just showing this information it would
simply remove these rows of data from
the database
so that's that and let's also check
update similar just like delete we have
update
so let's check update to
now here's how update works you say
update table name and then you set the
value of column column one to Value one
column two to Value two column three to
Value three where a condition holds true
so let's try update maybe let us change
the
reporting person for Jenny Leslie
Jennings and Leslie Thompson so who are
we going to set them to report to
maybe let's set them to report directly
to the president maybe Diane Murphy
directly wants to talk to the sales
people in San Francisco so we want to
get
these employees where job title sales
rep and the office code is one
and we want to update their values so
let's see we say update
what does that code look like
update set column one equals value one
column two equals value two okay so we
want to set update employees
and we want to set their
reports to
to one zero zero two
again we should put in quotes here
update employees set reports two to one
zero zero two and then we want to have
the WHERE and in the where Clause is
where we want to add the selection where
we are only selecting the sales reps
from San Francisco so where job title
equals sales rep and office code equals
one okay
all right so the good thing about SQL is
that it's very readable so update the
employees table and set reports 2 to 1 0
0 2 where job title is sales rep and
office code is one so only for people in
the San Francisco office or sales reps
you want to update their employee
we want to update their reports too and
let's just do a select star and let's
make sure that that was updated
select star from
employees
yeah so now you can see with Leslie
Jennings and Leslie Thompson they now
report to one zero zero two
okay if we remove this we can also see
that no other rows were affected you can
see that there are very few other people
who actually report to one zero zero two
all right
so that is the select Clause the where
close the update command and the delete
command so here are some
exercises for you
try and list customers in the United
States with a credit limit higher than
a thousand dollars so you'd probably
start out something like this you would
say
select star
from customers
where
country
equals I think it's USA
you can check this out so these are all
the customers in in the USA quite a few
of them but we want customers with a
credit limit higher than a thousand
dollars
maybe we probably want even an even
higher credit limit but let's see let's
try a credit limit higher than thousand
dollars so here you would say country
equals USA and then you would say and
credit
limit
greater than
a thousand
or let's try ten thousand let's see if
there are any more than ten thousand
more than a hundred thousand
yeah so there are nine rows with more
than hundred thousand but with a
thousand there are 35 rows so you can
see that changing the credit limit is
going to change the number of results
all right then here's one more list the
employee codes for the sales
representatives of customers in Spain
France and Italy
okay how would you do that well you
would say select
sales
first let's describe customers so let's
say describe
customers
so we have the sales rep employee number
so now we would say select
sales rep employee number from
customers
and then we can put in a where
and now we want the location of the
customer or the country
and we can put in an in and then I think
we can given a give it a list of values
so we are concerned with we are
concerned with Spain France and Italy so
we can now put in
pain
I think we have to use double quotes
here so Spain
France
Italy okay so here is the list of all
the sales reps
who work with customers in Spain France
and Italy okay now I can probably just
put put together a list of these so
there's one three seven zero one three
one three three seven uh
one seven zero two one four zero one and
one four yeah that seems to be all so
there are only about four or five such
sales reps and then the question is make
another query to list the names and
email addresses of those employees so
now we can do
select
let's say first name
last name
email from
employees
where
employee number
in
and then give it this list
okay so now we have Louis bondor Gerard
Hernandez Pamela Castello and Martin
Gerard so these are all the people who
are selling to customers in Italy Spain
and France
so this is the kind of q a that you can
do using
SQL queries
here's one more change the job title
sales rep to sales representative I'll
let you work on this you can use update
to do this delete entries for the sales
representatives working in London
so first you find out the sales rep
first you find out the code for the
London office how do you do that well
you can use a select statement to get
the data for London then you use that
code that office code to delete the
entries for those sales representatives
so you'll have a where Clause with
delete then you have show list of
employees who are not sales
representatives I think we've already
done that and here's one interesting one
show a list of customers with toys in
their name so this is where you would
have to use the like
statement so if I just click through
here you can see this is how the like
statement works
so you can say select columns from table
where a certain column is like a certain
pattern
and the pattern can be a string or the
pattern can be something like this you
can have a percentage or percentage a
so whenever you have a percentage
that means
0 or more
characters so if you want to just check
for a somewhere in between like if you
just want to check for or somewhere in
between then you have percentage or
percentage
so percentage represents zero or more
characters and then underscore
represents exactly one character okay so
check out this reference on how exactly
it works what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just try and solve this answer
show a list of customers with toys in
their name so let me see select
star from or maybe just select the
customer name
and the country
from customers
where
customer name
like
and here is where we can put in
percentage and then we want toys
and percentage
and let's run that
oops I think I had to close it so let me
just undo that
percentage twice percentage and let's
run that okay so it seems like you have
land of toys Incorporated in the USA you
have toys of Finland in Finland and you
have toys for grown-ups in USA and
boards and toys in USA so it's a very
basic selection you can't do a lot of
advanced regex kind of selection but a
very basic selection can be done a very
basic search can be done using like
okay then you have product lines and
products so you have a bunch of product
lines like motorcycles flights uh planes
cars Etc
and then you also have products so you
may have different models of motorcycles
different makes for which you offer
small scale models
so here is what they look like product
line is a very simple table it contains
the product line it contains some
description so it seems like it contains
a text description here for some reason
there's also an HTML description maybe
this is going to be used on the website
and there's also an image yeah so let's
just take create the
product line stable
once again I'm just going to paste it
here and that will create the product
lines table
and similarly we have the products table
as well which has a product code product
name product code is the primary key it
has a product line which is a foreign
key
and it has a product vendor description
it has a quantity in stock so that's a
small integer
then it has a Buy price so which is the
price at which we are buying let's say
the raw materials for the product or
sort of the manufacturing price then we
have the retail price so this is the
price at which we are selling the
product
so that can be used to just determine
the profit on the product
so here's our product right
and then once again you can use this
link to
download some products
so here we have the SQL file and then
from the SQL file let's see let's find
some product lines and some products so
let me get all these product lines I am
going to come back here
and I'm going to just put all these
product lines in
and I'm going to just run this
so we have put in all the product lines
classic cars motorcycles planes ships
trains truck vintage cars
and let's also put in a bunch of
products let's get all of these products
from this page
okay quite a few products and let's put
it in there
there you go
so now we should have a bunch of
products and a bunch of product lines as
well okay
now once you have such huge tables and
such huge such a large number of
products and product lines and such you
may want to do some sort of ordering and
you may want to also limit the number of
results you may not want to look at
thousands of results all the time or
even hundreds you may just want to look
at the top five or top 10. so if you
want to order data then you just include
order by at the end of a select
statement and you just mention which
columns you want to alter by so column
one column two so first it will try to
order by column one if the values in
column one are equal then it will try to
order by column two and so on and then
you have the ascending and descending
for example if you want to list
customers by country you would say
select
let's say customer name
comma country
from customers
order by
country
and now you can see that you have
customers ordered by country Australia
Austria Belgium Canada Etc
you can also then use a limit Clause if
you just want to then see maybe just one
page of data something that you can
display it once so you can also type
here limit 10.
and now you just see 10 and of course
you don't have to use order by with
limit you can use a limit
without order by as well
so if I just do limit 10 so this is now
the natural order or the order in which
the data was inserted that is the most
that is the default order that is used
so this is how you combine order by
limit and you then you can also combine
it by where Clause maybe you can also
only check for
customers which have a credit limit
greater than a thousand dollars so let's
say
select customer name country from
customers where
credit limit
greater than
a hundred thousand
and
order by
country limit five
right so maybe also get the credit limit
here
so that's how you combine all of these
here we are combining select
we are combining where we are combining
order by and limit and this is what that
looks like okay
so here are some exercises for you
identify the five most expensive
products from the plane's product line
identify the products that are about to
run out of stock so products which have
a quantity in stock less than 100.
and list 10 products in the motorcycle
category with the lowest Buy price
and with more than a thousand units in
stock okay so there are a lot of things
you'll probably have to put together
everything that we have covered so far
order by and not order buy but you will
have to put together a limit you will
have to put together an order buy as
well because the lowest Buy price and
you have to put together a couple of
conditions which is the category product
line
and for the product line you will have
to figure out what the product line code
for motorcycles is and you will also
have to add a check on the units in
stock
okay
then you have these orders order details
and payments tables so I'll let you
build these as an exercise you have the
code you have all the information here
so you can create the order order
details and payments tables using the
create table statement and include
proper primary key and foreign key
constraints so for example order has a
customer number order details has a
order number and a product code and then
payments also has a customer number
and the check number is the primary key
and then you can use the same sample
data that we've been using so far to
populate this too okay
next I just want to briefly touch on how
you can modify the structure of a table
not something that we will do right now
but if you want to add a new column to a
table here's how you do it you say alter
table table name
and then add and then the column name
and the data type and that's going to
add the column
maybe let's do it very quickly for
employees
so alter table let's see employees the
let's let's check the employees table
first employees
so describe employees and now let us
maybe add the date that they were hired
on
so we will add we will say altered table
employees
what's that add yeah add and then the
column name
hired on
and we want it to be a date
okay seems like that was added
so now if we check describe employees
you should see that there is a
hired on column and if I want to insert
an employee
insert into employees
if I insert an employee now I can
probably then I can probably then add
some information let's say set employee
reports to etc etc so we can probably
set the hired information right
so hired on to one zero zero two
and
let me change this to an actual date so
12 0 1.
okay so now if you check employees again
let me just get these employees
so select star
select star from employees
where job title is such and data search
so you can see now with these employees
we have a hired on column and in the
hired on column the value is 2020 1201
and for the other employees you will see
that the hired on column does not have
that value so that's how you add data
nothing too special nothing too
complicated it's just one more thing to
know
you add a column and similarly you can
drop columns using the drop column
command
you can modify column using the modify
column command
you can rename column using the rename
column command and here you say rename
old name old column name to new column
name after alter table
so as an exercise try adding removing
and modifying one column in each of the
tables created and what happens check
what happens when you remove or rename a
column that is a primary key because
that is the primary key which is also
used as a foreign key
yeah so do try that out so if you change
the employee code for example the
employee number now that is used in a
bunch of different tables like the
customer table
so what happens when you change the
employee number column try it out that's
the best part about interactive
environments like this you can try out
things and you can break things and
figure out what happens
now you can also place a bunch of SQL
commands into a DOT SQL file like this
one that we've been looking at so far
and then you can
execute all of these commands together
you can see that here we are dropping
the database we are then creating a
database we are then using that database
then we are creating a table offices we
are creating a table employees
we are creating a table customers
product clients products orders order
details payments and then we are
inserting data into each of these tables
right so this SQL files is basically
what's called a database dump that
somebody had this database and then they
exported it and we'll see how to export
it as well but now you can take this
data and import it into or just run all
these SQL commands and automatically
import the data into your
SQL Server into your SQL database
and here is how you do it so you there
are two ways to do it one is through the
command line now through the command
line let's say go back here
I exit I exit the actual command line
and let me come to my desktop which is
where I have this file database.sql
so I have this file here database.sql
and I can check this file
it contains exactly what I was looking
at I have just downloaded this file here
so I find my MySQL binary which is in
slash user slash local slash MySQL slash
bin slash MySQL so this is the MySQL
command line tool
and then I say minus U root so I want to
log in as the root user and then I also
say minus P because I want to use a
password and then this is the magic part
where you use this less than symbol and
I'll tell you how to think about this so
you have this less than simple
database.sql so what you're indicating
here is take the data in database dot
SQL and passes at pass it as inputs to
this command
so now we're no longer opening up the
console but we are taking all of these
commands inside the SQL file and passing
it as inputs to mySQL which we are
logging into as the root user so when I
run this let me just just to make things
very simple what I'll do is I'll first
just open MySQL
slash user slash local slash MySQL
slash bin slash MySQL so I'm just going
to open this first
minus U
root minus p
I'm just going to open this first and
I'm going to drop
database
classic models
okay and let me just do show databases
and you can see that we don't have
classic models here
so now we have we run this code MySQL
minus U root minus p database.sql and
this should take all those lines of code
and it should execute them against this
server
yeah I'll take a minute or two but it's
done
and now if we come back here into this
or if we just open up MySQL now and just
log in
and do show databases
you can see that we now have classic
models and it is now showing a showing
up in a upper case because in this
script file the database when it was
created it was created with this
uppercase in uppercase M but as such you
can still just say use classic models
without
upper case we can just say classic
models and it should work just fine
and now you can do show tables
and you have all these tables customers
employees offices Etc and now we can do
select
star from
offices
and you can see that these are all the
offices that we have right so even
though it shows up as uppercase here
because that's how it was created but
you can still access it as lowercase
uppercase or this title case or whatever
right so we have taken all that
information and then we have taken all
these lines of SQL code and we have
executed them on the database
so that's how you execute data one other
way to do it is you can also do it this
way from MySQL workbench you can click
on this or you can see open SQL page it
open SQL
button so you have this open SQL file
button here the second button click on
it and go to desktop and just open it up
now depending on which database you're
using the UI will be a little different
but the concept here is that you can do
this you can take a bunch of SQL code
and then you can execute all at once and
it should do the exact same thing
so here it drops the database so it's
going to empty the database and then
it's going to add all this information
and now if you just refresh here you
should find classic models and inside it
you should find these tables and then
you can maybe click on employees and you
can see all the employees
so you have all the employees just fine
one other thing you can do is you can
export data out so there are a couple of
ways to do this one is to
use the MySQL dump utility so the same
place where you have the MySQL
utility which is at
let me just exit here
so we have at user local MySQL bin again
this will be different on Windows or
probably different on Linux as well but
you can find it quite easily just look
it up so user local MySQL bin MySQL
right so this is how you open the
command line this is what we have been
looking at so far but you have a MySQL
dump utility
so you can call MySQL dump and I want to
use the root user and I want to use a
password
and what is how does it work so we have
to
provided the name of the database
so we provide the name of the database
after minus U or even at the beginning
so MySQL dump the database that we want
to dump is called classic models
and then there are certain options that
you can specify that do you want to have
these drop table lines so if you see
here before every table creation there's
no doubt there's no drop table statement
but we can add that drop table statement
as well by specifying this option and
again you would just have to look up the
documentation online to figure out how
exactly this
all these options work but yeah MySQL
dump
draw add drop table classic models minus
U root minus p
okay and that has created this
SQL file
oh but we forgot to write it to a file
we want to actually write it to a file
so right now it is just printed it out
so what we want to do is instead of
printing out all this information we
want to write it into let's say
DB dump dot SQL
okay
and just like that this should be now
there should be now this file dbdump.sql
we should have all the information that
we're looking for
so it has it has this drop table if
exists customer then create table
and then below it it has the data for
customers so insert into customers and
you have all this customer data
and then you have data for employees
then you have data for offices
and so on okay now there seems to be
some encoding error here for some reason
this is treated as binary I think it's
probably the office location that is
causing an issue but as such everything
seems to be just fine
and then you can take this and then you
can use that to reload the data now here
it does not have the commands to
actually create the database I'm sure
there is some option that you can
specify in SQL dump to create the
database if it does not exist and drop
an existing database as well so I'll let
you figure that out
but
yeah but this is what we are interested
in
and this is something you can do if you
connect to a remote database right now
we are connecting to a local database
but if you connect to a remote database
on some server you can export all its
data into a SQL file
and then there are converters in in
pandas what you can do is you can
actually load up SQL files
maybe let's try that maybe let's do file
open here and
let us upload
I'm not too sure but I think this might
work so let us upload database.sql
yeah and you should be able to do
something like this import pandas
as PD
and then PD dot read SQL
and let's see
oh I think this needs to be a SQL
command and a connection so it's not
going to work with a SQL file you need
to actually connect to a database so we
look at it the next time but yeah but
there are ways to read that SQL file
there are ways to convert SQL files into
a bunch of CSV files I know that there
are ways to convert that into a bunch of
different formats so exporting it is
useful because you can then load back
that data into a new database server or
you can also convert it into different
formats
so try this out on your own download the
SQL file import the data from your local
installation of MySQL server and
then export the classic models database
into a SQL file then drop the classic
models database and then recreate it
using your exported file so make sure
that your exported file can actually
recreate the data that's an important
thing you should be able to do
okay so with that we reach the end of
today's lesson there's not much more
that we're going to cover today there is
a lot more that we need to cover in SQL
but we'll talk about the next time
but here are some challenges for you to
try out so this classic models data set
is taken from this website
richardwatson.com this is I think this
is a professor and they teach a database
management course
so you can and there are a bunch of
exercises here so today what we've
covered are mostly the single entity
exercises but you also have these other
exercises which require
some joins and some other things which
you have not covered yet
so you may just want to try out
this prepare a list of offices sorted by
country state and city this should be
straightforward how many employees are
there in the company okay this will
require some sort of aggregation
or you can just look at the list of
employees but yeah but one thing you
should check out is
you can check out things like count
where's count
yeah count average in sum
so you can do something like this select
count column name from table where
condition
and you can use that to answer this
question how many employees are there in
the company so here is how I would do it
I would say
select count
star from
employees
and just use
classic models okay
select select count star from employees
and it tells you that there are 23
employees
then here is a question what is the
total of all the payments received so
let's see select star from payments
and you have all these payments
and now among these payments there is
this amount column so if you just want
to get the total amount we say select
amount and then we can do a sum how do
we do a sum well I think it should be
there here somewhere so we can just do a
sum on the column
so we do select
sum of amount
from payments
so this is the total payment that we
have received now you can do things like
what is the total payment we have
received from customers based in the USA
or from a particular location and you
can do like a group buy as well and
we'll cover Group by and all the next
time
then you have questions like list of
product lines that contain cars
and Report total payments for October 28
2004 so here's a where Clause report
those payments greater than a hundred
thousand dollars
list of products in each product line
how many products in each product line
okay
so this might be worth figuring out you
may have to
use this as a reference w3schools is a
good reference here you can check out
and see which one of these might be
useful for you
then what is the average percentage
markup on MSRP on the Buy price so now
you are comparing you're doing
arithmetic between two columns again
something that we'll try and cover the
next time
how many distinct products does classic
models sell
report name and city of customers etc
etc so a whole bunch of questions and
whichever you are not able to figure out
right now using what we have covered
today just try and look through this
documentation so this is everything that
MySQL supports is listed here most
likely you will everything that you need
will be covered in this MySQL SQL
section if you just go through most of
these you should be able to answer these
questions
and then wherever we have more
one-to-many relationships or any
relationships between multiple tables we
will look at the next time so the next
time we will look at using functions for
advanced querying on strings dates
timestamps we will look at aggregating
data using count average sum min max we
will look at using joins to combine and
query data from multiple tables at once
we'll also see how to improve query
performance with keys indexes and
transactions and finally we will look at
how you can connect to a SQL database
from python for querying and
visualization in Jupiter so we'll look
at how to do it using pandas and we'll
also briefly try and look at orms so
there's a bunch of things to cover here
but the more important thing in SQL is
practice
so you wanna definitely try out these
challenges and there are solutions for
these challenges as well you can click
the solutions link and use that to check
the solutions for example there was this
query about
what is the average percentage markup of
the MSRP on Buy price
this is question number 11. so let's see
question number 11.
okay so seems like we are doing some
sort of a
calculation here so average of MSRP
minus Buy price divided by MSRP
multiplied by 100 as the average
percentage markup from products okay so
we'll also talk about as the next time
now a few resources for you one is the
SQL challenges for sure then the other
one is the W3 schools reference it's a
great guide to just quickly look through
all the different
SQL
all the different SQL
commands and all the different SQL
statements and keywords that are present
then there is this book called
dbbook.com so this is dbhyphenbook.com
It's called database systems Concepts uh
you can get this book if you wish it's a
great book but you should also check out
these slides so they have made the
slides available for free online and
these slides are a great comprehensive
introduction to SQL and relational
databases and
pretty much everything to do with a
relational databases so you can use
these slides just whenever let's say
you're preparing for interviews or if
you want to get a deeper theoretical
understanding of how the whole thing
works
do check out these slides I think you'll
find them useful now you just need to
look at part one relational languages
where we talk about relational models
introduction to SQL intermediate SQL
Advanced SQL Advanced is already beyond
what you will need to know but if you
cover these four or five slide decks and
maybe also the introduction
then you will pretty much Master SQL at
least you will know everything there is
to know then you'll just need to
practice
then you also have these slides on
database design which is about the
entity relationship diagrams and models
you don't need to know this as a data
science practitioner generally somebody
else is going to do the database design
but if you want to interpret entity
relationship diagrams correctly then you
should check this out this might be
useful for you the rest of it is not
really that important not something that
is relevant here it goes into the
internals of databases but definitely
check out chapters 2 to 5 of dbbook.com
so you want to go to dbhyphenbook.com
go to the seventh edition and click on
slides
and here you have
um all these slides that you can access
here they also have some sample tables
just like we had this SQL file for
creating the classic
models data set similarly you have
sample tables for creating this
University data set so where you have
departments and instructors and students
and courses and prerequisites and
students take courses and instructors
teach courses and then each course is
taught in a section with a certain time
slot and then instructors are also
advisors for students so it's a
interesting data set it has about 2000
rows of data and then there are a bunch
of questions that you can try and answer
on this data set as well I think they
are mentioned somewhere here in the yeah
exercises so you see there are some
exercises here on accessing the database
basic SQL intermediate SQL Advanced SQL
yeah so here
so there's a a SQL is all about
exercising all about trying out these
exercises so dude maybe we'll try and
put all of this together into a single
notebook and we will also see
we'll also find a way to do it so that
you can type all the code in Jupiter and
get the results immediately in fact
Jupiter just like python there is a way
to type SQL directly into Jupiter and
interact directly with the database so
we'll try and set that up for the
assignment but in the meantime do check
out dbbook.com you also want to get
familiar with the workbench or whatever
tool your company is going to use so
don't lean too much on Jupiter for this
particular course especially and SQL in
particular
become used to this workbench become
used to working with the command line
and typing commands there because that
is how you will be working with SQL
databases in the real world okay and we
will touch on how to access them using
python 2.
more SQL exercises on w3resource.com you
have more exercises hundreds of
exercises really and that's all SQL is
about exercises and more and if you
really want to read through my sequels
reference manual then you can check that
as well although you would almost never
need to do that
and that's it so we've just covered the
use cases and the design of relational
databases in SQL we've looked into the
installation of MySQL and how to set up
a database locally we looked at creating
modifying and deleting databases and
database tables
we looked at SQL data types and
constraints like primary key and foreign
key we looked at the create read update
and delete operations on database tables
and we looked at exporting and importing
data from relational databases
the topic for today is aggregation and
joins with SQL last time we looked at
some basic SQL
commands we saw how to create databases
we saw how to create tables we saw how
to put data into tables how to get data
out of tables all the crad operations
which is create read update and delete
and we also looked at basic querying
using select with some conditions
today we are going to look at
aggregation grouping and pagination in
SQL queries then we will look at mapping
functions arithmetic and how to work
with dates
we will also combine data from different
tables using SQL joins and we learn how
to improve query performances with
indexes and views
we will also talk about how we can
execute SQL queries using Python and SQL
Alchemy towards the very end
and as I've said this is a continuation
of the previous tutorial so do check out
the previous tutorial if you haven't
done that already
this contains all the basics of SQL
and we will be setting up a MySQL server
locally so typically how a relational
database works is you have to download
this software called the server in a
server in computer science is simply a
program which runs in the background and
listens for instructions so the MySQL
server is something that you can
download from dev.m.mysql.com
this is just a package that you download
to your computer and then you install it
on your computer and once you install it
on your computer
you can start up a database server on
your computer so that software is
running now in the background and you
can then issue instructions or send
instructions to the database server in
the form of SQL queries like creating
databases creating tables putting data
in taking data out Etc
now depending on your operating system
the way to start and stop this server is
going to be different in my case
what MySQL does is
when I install MySQL Community server
it adds a system preferences pane so
inside my system preferences this is the
Mac system preferences there is a MySQL
page that gets added but in your case
this could be different so make sure
that you have downloaded MySQL server
the software and then it is running on
your computer
and then
anytime you have a server running you
need a way to connect to that database
server so there are multiple ways to
connect to a database server one of them
is to use
the MySQL command line which is
typically installed at some kind of a
location like this slash user slash
local MySQL this is on Mac again the
MySQL command line tool based on your
operating system will be at a different
location so check out the documentation
or search online on where you can find
the MySQL command line tool once the
community server is installed
so one way you can connect to the server
and issue commands to the server is by
running the MySQL command line and here
you specify that you want to log in as
the user root so when you install the
server you're asked to set up a password
for the database server and a username
so the default username is root and you
have to set a password so in my case I
have set up a certain password and now I
am connected to
the server and now I can issue commands
to the server for example I can say show
databases
and that's going to show me the
databases I have but what we're going to
do is use
software called the MySQL workbench so
this is the second piece of software
you'll have to install and I have given
you a link here
dev.m.mysql.com download slash workbench
so go to this page and download the
MySQL workbench for your computer for
your laptop for your operating system
and then open it up so now we have a
server that's running on our computer
and then we have this workbench which
can connect to a server and gives you a
graphical user interface to connect to
that server so one way you can connect
to your service click plus and here you
can then provide
this is a connection name that you can
set but you have to provide some
parameters by default this is set to
connect to a local machine a local
database server on your computer but
again if you have a database server that
is somewhere on the cloud you can simply
ask for the host name Port username
password
and then you can connect to that server
as well so MySQL workbench does not just
collect connect to your local database
it can connect to any database on the
cloud if you have the credentials and
when you join a company they will give
you the credentials to the server
in my case I already had the local
instance set up here so I just clicked
on it and now I'm connected to my local
instance for example if I just type
show databases
that's going to show me the databases
that I have here which is classic models
information schema MySQL and performance
schema and then I can run use database
in all my select queries okay so that's
the setup you need to do that's the
software you need to have installed and
let us know if you face issues and I
hope the server and the workbench
a separation is clear to you
so here's the MySQL workbench we have
that running and in this tutorial we
will use the classic models database
from the previous tutorial so classic
models is a hypothetical company it's a
distributor of small scale models of
cars motorcycles planes ships trains Etc
and the products that are manufactured
by classic models are sold in toy and
gift stores around the world so here are
some of the
products they sell and classic models
has offices around the world with dozens
of employees and the customers of
classic models are typically toy or Gift
Stores so each customer has a designated
sales representative who is an employee
of classic models that they interact
with
now customers typically Place orders
requesting several products in different
quantities and then they pay for
multiple orders at once via checks all
right so that's the setup here we have
this com this hypothetical company which
does all of these activities and we want
to track all their activities in a
relational database and to do that
an entity relationship diagram has been
given to us and this simply tells us
what the different entities or what the
different tables in the database are and
what the different columns within those
tables are so we have an offices table
here it contains information about
different offices or the primary key is
office code which is the unique
identifier
then we have the employees table so we
have an employee number last name first
name extension email Etc and there are a
couple of relationships here there is an
office code in employees so for every
employee there is an office code which
is the office code of a certain office
so this is called a foreign key because
an employee cannot have an office code
which is invalid
and then you also have reports too so
reports to tells you which employee and
employee reports to so this is a foreign
key from the employee table to itself
right so reports too must be a valid
employee number of another employee
then you have customers and you have a
bunch of information about customers
customer number is the primary key and
every customer has a sales rep employee
number which is
the employee number of a certain
employee who's a sales rep
and then for customers a customers can
place orders
so every order is placed by a customer
that's why you have a customer number
foreign key here but apart from that
orders can have a lot of items so there
is an order details table for each item
each line item
in the order
let's say you've ordered five products
you have five line items and you can
have the quantity Etc of each one
and then you have products as well so
there's a table of products and there's
a table of product clients because you
need to track information about the
product somewhere as well
finally you have payments customer main
customers make payments at separate
times so this is a slightly different
flow where you don't pay per order but
customers have a credit limit which
means they can make Place orders up to a
certain amount and then they can clear
all their pending payments at once using
a check
so that's the setup they have here and
depending on how your company operates
this system may be different it's
possible that if you take payments up
front then maybe the order details is
connected to payments or the order is
connected to a payment rather than a
customer okay so that's the entity
relationship diagram here and that's the
sort of the overview of the database
that we're working with now we will use
we will set up this database locally
with some sample data using a script so
let me just set that up and then we will
take some questions
and by the way if you have any questions
please post them in the zoom chat so to
set up this database
we first need to download the SQL script
so I'm just going to open this in a new
tab and that's going to try and download
it
and I'm just going to download it on my
desktop here
and you can see that now the SQL script
is downloaded on the on my desktop and
then once you have downloaded it
you can go to file
open SQL script in your MySQL workbench
so open up MySQL workbench connect to
the local database and click on this
open SQL script
and then here you can see the contents
of the SQL script so this contains
all the information to set up the
database that we just saw the ERD for
the entity relationship diagram for and
it also contains a lot of sample data
for example it's going to drop the
database classic models if it exists
it's going to then create a new database
and it's going to use that database then
it's going to create
tables one by one for example here it's
creating the offices table with all this
information and then it is going to
create employees
customers etc etc
once tables are created it is going to
insert data into these tables like
product lines products customers
employees Etc okay so it's going to set
up a database with a lot of information
for us
now once you have this SQL script loaded
up you will see this run SQL
so execute button which is like a
lightning button here so you can just
run a press that or you can just press
command enter or control enter on
windows so I'm just going to run
command enter and now my previous
classic models database has been removed
and this new database has been set up so
if I go to the left sidebar if your
sidebar is not open you can click here
and open up the left sidebar and just go
to the schemas tab in the left sidebar
I should be able to find
a schema
let me just connect again here
okay let me just run that once again
yep all right so now if I check the
schemas here so I should be able to find
in the schemas once I reload the schemas
the classic models database
now in the classic models database I can
browse all the tables here you can see
that we have tables customers employees
offices order details payments product
lines Etc
and if you
double click on a table or if you just
click on this table click on this button
which shows information from the table
then it is you can view some information
from each table all right so MySQL
workbench gives you an easy way to
browse the schema see different tables
and actually look at information from
different tables very easily
okay
so now we have just to recap we have
downloaded the SQL script
from this URL and then we have
loaded it into MySQL workbench using
file open SQL script
then we have executed the script to
create and populate the database this
part can also be done using the MySQL
command line tool it's simply a matter
of passing the script to the command
line tool and you can look up how to do
that but once executed you should be
able to view and browse all the tables
in the schema section of the sidebar
and if you face an error the most likely
issue is that your MySQL server is not
running so just because you have
workbench open does not mean the server
is running so make sure that the server
is running and then you will be able to
communicate with the database server all
right so with that we have our database
set up now ready to go and we have our
MySQL workbench connected
so let's get started
the first topic we look at is
aggregation grouping and aliases
SQL provides several functions like
count average sum Min and Max for
aggregating the results of a query what
do you mean by aggregating well it's
combining the results that you get
typically into a single number or maybe
a one or one or more numbers so here's
an example
report the total number of payments
received before October 28 2004.
okay so this is the kind of question
that will be posed to you or the kind of
information that you will have to figure
out now we know from the ER diagram and
we know from
let's maybe just copy the question and
put it here
yeah so this is the way to create a
comment in a SQL file or a SQL query you
just put in hyphen hyphen space and
that's going to be a comment that is
going to be ignored by the
uh by the MySQL server
okay so the question is report the total
number of payments received before
October 28 2004. so we have a table
called payments
so let me just do a select star
from payments
all right and once I run that I will get
back
a list of results
yeah here's the list of results so these
are all the payments in the database you
have a check number you have a payment
date you have an amount and you have a
customer number the customer who made
the payment all right but we are not
interested in all the payments we are
interested in payments received before
October 28 2004. so there is a payment
date here and it seems like this payment
date is in this year month date format
and in fact if you want to know the data
type of this payment date you can just
spin up a new query here and just type
describe
payments
and you can see that the payment date is
a date time okay now a date time is an
ordered field obviously dates have a
intrinsic order so here's what you can
do you can say select start from
payments where
payment date
is less than because we want payments
before October 28 2004 and then you
provide the date that you want to check
here
so that's 2004
and then you have
October that is the 10th month and then
you have 28. so this should be enough
you don't need to put in the time here
so I'm just going to run that
and if you see now we only have
payments that have occurred before
October 24 October 28 2004.
and I recommend just going through this
list manually if you want to verify this
but
that's that's how you get that all right
but we don't want every single payment
we want the total number of payments now
if you want a total number of payments
it's very simple to we simply want to
count the number of rows that were
returned by this query and the way to do
that is just type count
so count is a function in SQL and you
can see it highlighted in green
and typically this is what we do we put
all the SQL
commands in
so typically this is what we do we put
all the SQL keywords on the SQL
functions in capital letters or
uppercase and we put
the column names in lowercase or
whatever is the actual column name
whether it uses lowercase uppercase or
combination of both and this is just to
visually separate actual keywords with
column names but remember that SQL is
completely
case insensitive so you could type all
of these in lowercase and you could type
all of these in uppercase and it would
work just fine okay
and this is just for visual separation
in any in any case we have the count
function so you just put instead of
Select count star uh use instead of
Select star you just type select count
star and run that
and now you will see here that there are
189 payments that have been made before
October 28 2004 and if you did not have
this where Clause this filter then you
can see that there are total of 273
payments so out of 273 payments 100 and
89 payments were made before October 28
2004.
so that's how you count the number of
rows
returned from a query just put in
account
located and there's a quick question
here about payments where this payment
stable come from so this is the table
that we've just populated when we
downloaded the SQL file classic
models.sql and then we executed it
that gave us this table and that gave us
all the data inside this table
okay
so that's count just put count around
the selection criteria and that will
count the table that will count the rows
for you
next another common use case involves
counting the number of distinct values
in a column
so here's a question report the number
of customers who have made payments
before October 28 2004. so now we are no
longer interested in the number of
now we are no longer interested in the
number of payments that were made we are
interested in the number of unique
customers who have made payments and one
customer can make multiple payments uh
so number of customers who have made
payments before October 28 2004.
so once again maybe let's open up a new
uh let's just continue typing here
so here's my select query select star
from
payments and I can write payments or I
can write payments or I can write
payments and it will all be the same
thing
okay this is the name of the table so
anything you see after from is a table
name
so select star from payments that gives
us a list of all the payments and once
again we want to select them
and I'm just going to mix cases here but
don't worry about it so let's just say
select start from payments where
payment date
is less than
2004 10
what's that October 28th so 2004 1028 so
that gives us all the payments that have
occurred before
2004 1028. now we are interested in the
customer number we are interested in the
unique customers who have made payments
before the state
so here's the first thing I'll do maybe
I'll just select the customer number
first
okay so if I just select customer number
now I have ignored all the other columns
I have just selected the customer number
column so now I have 2299 172 242 Etc
but of course there are probably going
to be repetitions here and you can go
through this list and verify that there
are some repetitions okay so if I did
select count
customer number
this is giving me 189 which is actually
the total number of rows returned
but we want simply the number of unique
customers who have made payments
so what you do is you type distinct
okay now when you type distinct
repetitions from this list will go away
so if I type distinct here
now you can verify that this list is a
bit smaller this list is not that big
anymore
and in fact if I type count now
you will see that the count is only 98.
so what distinct does when you type
distinct before a column name it is
going to just select distinct values of
that column and if you type multiple
column names after distinct it is going
to just select all the distinct
combinations but in this case we first
get the list of all the distinct
customer number which is a customer ID
and then we count the number of rows
okay so count is a function but distinct
is still a keyword which is part of the
SQL
syntax
okay so once again I'm just quickly
going to repeat that we have select star
from payments where payment date is less
than October 28 2004 now instead of
selecting all the columns I just select
customer number
and that gives me the customer number
for each payment but I'm only interested
in the distinct customer numbers I don't
want to show I don't want customer
numbers to show up again and again so I
type distinct and then I want to count
them so here is the count function which
is going to count the customer numbers
for me and there are 98 of them
okay so that's how you solve any SQL
query or solve any SQL question you just
go step by step you start by looking at
the table and then you simply keep
adding in criteria one by one
of course as I said District can be used
can also be used without count so if you
just wanted the list of customer numbers
for customers who have made a payment
before the 28th of October 2004 then you
just type select distinct customer
number from payments where payment date
is less than 28th of October 2004.
okay and you can use distinct with
multiple columns as well so if you want
to try out learn more and try out what
distinct does
check out some documentation here on
w3schools
and you can also practice this online
okay now
if I look back at this query just a
distinct customer numbers
this is just giving me a list of
customer numbers right and this is not
very informative because ideally what we
want is details of those customers I
want to know which people which
stores have made payments before the
28th of October 2004. so how do you do
that well here is one way to do that we
know that this is a list
and
you can write a query
which uses the result of this query okay
and here's what we want to answer we
want to retrieve the details
for all the customers who have made a
payment before October 28 2004 okay so
how do we do that let me just put this
query aside for a second and let me
start typing
and let's just comment it out here and
let me start typing select
star from customers
okay
I guess I'm just going to use lowercase
here but select star from customers
so now I have details of all the
customers but I'm not interested in all
the customers I am interested in simply
the customers where
the customer number
is in this list that I had earlier and
I'm just going to run this again here in
a
as a new query
so I just want to
get the details of customers who are in
this list about 98 or so customers so
what I can do is I can take this query
without the semicolon
and I can come back here
I can come back here select start from
customers where customer number
in and then here I have to give a list
so instead of giving this actual list I
can give a query which generates that
list so I can just put in a bracket here
and type select distinct customer number
from payments where payment date okay so
we take the result of this query select
distinct customer number from payments
where payment date and then we run a
second query which is going to select
details from the customers table where
the customer number
lies in this list okay so if we run that
now
so now you will only get details of
customers where the customer number is
in this list and what is this list this
list is simply then
distinct customer numbers
from the payments column where the
payment date is less than 2004 1028 okay
so that's how you change SQL queries you
can take the result of one SQL query and
use it in a where clause or you can even
select from it again
so you can treat a treat the result of a
query as another table essentially
and then write SQL queries on top of the
results of other SQL queries okay
so that's how you chain queries
okay so here's an exercise for you
retrieve the details of all the
customers in the United States who have
made payments between April 1st 2003 and
March 31st 2004. so how would you do
this you would first
think about it the way you would do this
is first you would just look at all the
payments so you just do select star from
payments and then you would look at
payments
between April 1st 2003 and March 31st
2004. so you would put some kind of a
where Clause where you would combine two
conditions using an and
keyword and once you get the
results for payments just between these
two dates then you simply retrieve the
customer ID for those payments
and then once you have that list of
customer IDs or the distinct list of
customer IDs you can use that to get the
details of customers
and you add another where Clause where
you will check
whether the customer is in United States
or not so it's going to get a little
complex here but I will let you figure
this out and if you are unable to do it
uh do ask on the slack group and we'll
help you out
okay so let's talk about grouping then
so here's a question
find the total number of payments made
by each customer before October 28 2004.
all right let's go back and let's try
and solve this
so here's the question
total number of payments made by each
customer before October 28 2004.
so we say select star from payments
again
so we were selecting we want to show all
the columns from the payments table
all right and we just want to look at
payments before October 28 2004 so where
payment date
is less than
and now
we want to count the total number of
payments so we could do this count
but this is the total number of payments
across all customers we want to count
the number of payments made by each
customer
so here's what you can do
you can provide a
you can provide a group by Clause so you
can type something like this you can say
Group by
well I believe it shows up after where
so yeah this this can sometimes be
confusing which clause comes after which
but let's try here
well actually let's start with that and
then we'll see if that works so Group by
so you type select count start from
payments and group it by
customer number
so now you're just looking at
count star of payments and grouping by
customer numbers okay I think this this
comes after
yep
so you type select count star from
payments where payments date is less
than to 20 2014 28 and you Group by the
customer number so what happens here SQL
first creates or groups of groups of
rows for each customer number and then
it computes the sum or it computes the
count
of the number of rows for each customer
number so here it seems like for a
certain customer there are two rows for
a certain customer there are three rows
for another customer there is one row
Etc but of course we also want to see
the customer number so what we can do is
we can just take this customer number
column and select that too okay so
anytime you Group by a certain column
you can also show that column in the
result
so here's what that looks like select
count star
from payments
where payment date is less than a
certain value
select customer customer number comma
count star from payments where payment
data is less than a certain value and
group this data by customer number first
so first SQL creates groups for each
customer number then it performs this
count star and then it gives us a
customer number and the count star okay
now here's one other thing we can do
this is not very informative because
we're looking at count star here what we
can do is we can just say uh
number of payments
we can rename this count the output of
this count
as number of payments
okay this is called aliasing so now you
have this table where it says customer
number and it shows you the number of
payments and you can see that the
customer number 112 had two payments
before the state customer number 114 had
three payments and for each customer in
the database you get how many payments
they've made
only the customers who have made
payments before this particular date
so this is how you use Group by grouping
is very commonly used with aggregation
in functions like count
okay now apart from the count you can
also compute the sum of values in a
column so here's one thing you can try
and figure out find the total amount
paid by each customer which is the sum
of all their payments
before October 28 2004 so let's see if
we can do that I'm just going to once
again select
I'm just going to select start from
payment
s here and just see
what columns we have so we have a
payment date which we have been looking
at we've been looking at this customer
number but there is also this amount
so what we want to do is we want to
total up the amount for each customer so
let me go back here so now I have select
customer number and instead of count
star which is going to count the rows I
am going to call sum
and I'm going to sum the values in the
amount column so count you generally put
in Star because you're just counting the
number of rows so you don't have to
specify a column
but
when you want to compute the sum you
specify the column for which you compute
the sum so sum of amount and I'm going
to call that as total amount
okay so select customer number and some
amount which I'm calling total amount
from payments where payment date is less
than
28 October 2004 and group by the
customer number
and that now gives you for each customer
the total amount so all we've done is
we've replaced count star with some
amount
okay so these functions are generally
work all work in the same way some count
and you can also use them together so
here's an example find the total number
of payments and the total payment amount
for each customer for payments made
between uh before October 28 2004.
so how would we do that well we have
select customer number uh and then we
have the total amount already I'm just
going to add another column here so I'm
saying I'm going to say count star
as
number of payments
comma
yeah so we have select customer number
count Star as number of payments some
amount as total amount from payments
where payment date is less than such and
such and then we Group by customer name
so now we have for each customer what is
the number of payments they've made and
what is the total amount that they've
paid before this particular date and you
can try and remove this where clause and
see that the result actually changes and
you see now that the result is different
right
so try and understand each part of the
SQL query the same SQL queries mentioned
here so try and understand each part of
the query and if you can make sense of
it then you're getting familiar with SQL
and here's an exercise for you determine
the total number of units sold for each
product so there is a products column
and then there is a
so there is a order details column
I think
let's take a look at that quickly
select star
from order detail so there is an order
details table
and this contains the details of all the
orders that have been placed and then
here you have
the product code and you have the
quantity ordered
of that product in that particular order
and what we want to do is we want to
find the total number of units sold for
each product so if I simply do
Group by
product code
and here if I do
and I do a sum
and in the sum I put in the quantity
order
so now what we're saying is we want to
group the rows in order number in order
details by the product code and for each
product code we want to take a sum of
the quantity ordered column
and if we do that
and run this query
you should see here that we have the
product code and then for each product
code we have the quantity ordered okay
and that's how you answer this question
again becomes easier to understand once
you try it yourself so here's how I
would go about solving working through
this notebook just read the question
don't look at the answer just
immediately go to your SQL workbench and
then start typing out and start figuring
out how to solve the question and if
you're able to solve the question great
if you're not then you can look at the
answer and again don't copy paste the
answer look at the answer maybe for a
couple of minutes try and understand
what it does and then go back and try to
type it out again typing out code is a
very important part of becoming familiar
with
SQL or python or coding in general
okay
now apart from sum and count you can
also do the min max in average for
example if you want to figure out
what was the maximum payment made by
each customer before a certain date you
can do that all you need to do here is
in this
table you can maybe just add
max amount
as let's just call it largest payment
so now you have for each customer what
is the largest payment they've made
and you can see this here the largest
payment that they've made is a for this
person has made is a fourteen thousand
dollars they can also you can also add
the minimum amount that they've paid
so smallest payment
so the smallest payment they've made is
32 000. so already we're getting some
insights in it turns out that in this
case customer number one zero three the
largest num the largest payment is
fourteen thousand dollars and the
smallest is six thousand but for one one
two the largest payment is thirty three
thousand and the smallest is 32. so
maybe this customer is just clearing uh
bills as soon as they hit a certain
amount right you can also then look at
the average payment so what is the
average order amount and think it is
average okay
so what is the average amount and this
is the average payment
okay I think there's a an issue here I'm
not sure what the average is called but
let's see average my sequel
AV it's called AVG so let me just change
that to AVG
yeah so AVG is a function name here and
you can see that the average payment for
each customer is also shown here right
so this is how you can do basic analysis
directly within SQL you don't even have
to export the data although if you want
you could export it to a CSV file uh
that's an option
from the MySQL workbench but a lot of
analysis can be done directly within SQL
okay so let's talk about sorting and
pagination
now so far we've been doing all these
queries and through these queries we get
a lot of information but in a lot of
cases we are looking we are interested
in finding the a top 10 or top five or
the maximum value
so here's an example retrieve the
customer numbers for the 10 customers
who made the highest total payments in
2004.
or actually let me change that to
before October
28 2004 okay so retrieve the customer
number for customer numbers for 10
customers who made the highest payments
total payment before October 28 2004. so
let's try and answer this step by step
we want
to retrieve the customer number
so we can say select
star from payments
and once again we are interested in
payment date
before
October 28th
grade we have that information
but now we want to retrieve uh
we were interested in the highest total
payment so before that we are interested
in the total payment per customer so if
we do this if we do a group by
customer number
and then we do uh we select the customer
number for each group and then we do a
sum of the amount column
so now what that gives us is the total
the total amount paid by each customer
before October 28 2004 so we have that
but now we are interested in the people
who made the highest total payment so
here's what we can do we can type at the
end order by so we type order by
and then we tell the column name that we
want to order by so we want to order by
this column which is the sum the total
amount so let me just rename this as
total payment
so I'm going to call this column the sum
column I'm going to call it total
payment
and I want to order it by total payment
so let's run that
and Order bike generally comes at the
very end so now you have customer number
456 they have a total payment of 1679
customer number 381 has 2755 and so on
but of course we are interested not in
the lowest so this is ordered in
ascending order but we are interested in
the highest so to do that you type desc
descending so a ASC for ascending and
desc for descending and let's run that
so now you have the maximum value
31 33 sorry 331 256 dollars were spent
by customer number 141.
okay
and we have this information for all the
customers but the question asks only for
the top 10 customers and typically
anytime you issue queries like this in a
very large database
you probably only want to look at maybe
the top 10 the top 50 or the top hundred
so here's how you can do that you just
call at the end you type limit
and then you tell the number of rows
that you want to see in the result
okay so if I type limit a 10 at the very
end so that's going to just give us 10
results you can see these are the 10
customers uh
141 124 148 151 and 320.
okay and by the way limit Works without
order by as well it you don't need an
order you can do a limit just like this
too so these are both independent but in
general whenever you're doing an
ordering it's common practice to also
limit the number of results so as to not
put a very heavy load on the database
so that's what we created select
customer number and some amount as total
payment from payments where payment date
is less than this value and we Group by
customer number
order by total payment descending and
limit the results to 10.
now if you want to see the next 10
results because we've just limited the
results to 10 all we need to do is add
an offset so let's say we want to skip
ahead we want to skip the first 10 rows
and you want to see the next 10 rows we
type offset 10.
and just notice this number here 320 and
93565 if I type offset 10 you will see
that now we have 386 Which is less than
the previous value so now I'm no longer
looking at the top 10 I'm looking at the
next 10 so customer number 11 to 20 when
they are sorted by the total payment and
if it's let's say if I set the offset to
if I if I set the offset to 5 so I'll
just skip this query will just skip the
first five rows and it'll show me from
the sixth row onwards right so limit and
offset can be set independently limit
tells you how many rows you want offset
tells you how many rows you want to skip
now here I've skipped the first 50
customers so I'm looking at
customer number 51 to 60. okay and I
could maybe even if I wanted I could
look at
just five of these
so play around with limit and offset
they are used to limit and paginate the
queries
SQL also provides mapping functions and
these mapping functions are applied to
individual values so now we're no longer
combining multiple rows of data now we
are just applying them to individual
values
so here is a question display the full
name of the point of contact for each
customer in the United States in upper
case
along with their phone number
and we want this information to be
sorted by the alphabetical order of
customer name okay so there's a lot
going on in this question and these are
the kind of questions that you will see
in interviews often and don't feel
intimidated just go step by step
the first thing here is we want
information about customers
so we go here and let's clear all this
and we just type select star from
customers
great now we have information about
next we want customers in the United
States
so we have
what's that we have this country column
and in country we have USA so if I just
type where
country equals USA
so now I'm just looking at customers in
the United States and you can check here
then all of the all of them have Country
USA
okay great one more thing done next
we want to display the full name of the
point of contact for each customer
so if you see here we have contact first
name and we have contact last name so we
could do this we could just say
let's just print a customer name I think
that is something that we should display
and let us display
contact first name
and let us display contact
last name
okay
all right so now we have the customer
name we have the contact first name and
contact last name only for those
customers where country is set to USA
okay so display the full name
it's still not the full name we are
showing two separate columns but we'll
figure out that piece but here it says
we want to display these in uppercase
for some reason or maybe we want to
print them somewhere or copy paste this
information somewhere so how do you
convert a string into uppercase well
there's a function for that you just
call you case
so your case is going to make it
uppercase and L case is going to make it
lowercase
so I just call you case on first name
and let me maybe do L case for now on
contact name
and you can see here the first name
becomes upper uppercase all capital
letters or uppercase letters and the
last name has become lowercase let me
turn that into uppercase as well
so now we have both an uppercase
and notice that these are not
aggregation functions they did not
combine all the rows into a single value
they applied this function uppercase to
every individual value so this was
applied to Susan it was applied to this
row and this row and this row and so on
okay so that's why these are called
mapping values they take a column and
they map that column onto a based on a
function
so that's why these are called mapping
functions
now last bit here is or maybe a couple
more things left one is
display the full name so we want to take
the first name and last name and we want
to combine them so there are certain
functions which can combine columns and
the combination that we want to use here
is called concat concat is short for
concatenation so I'm just going to call
concat here
c-o-n-c-a-t and let me drop this for a
moment let me just get rid of these
and I'm just going to do customer
first name
and oh sorry this is contact so contact
first name and contact last name
so now we've combined contact first name
and contact last name but there's a
problem here you see Susan Nelson this
is there's no space between them
well that's easy to fix you just add a
space here
and now you have Susan Nelson
and we want to make this uppercase so
now concat first name Etc is the uh
string that we're dealing with or it's a
column that we're dealing with so we
just called you case here
and that is going to now make that
uppercase
now you could do it two ways you could
apply to each column first and then
concatenate them or you could apply it
outside both will do the same so now we
have that one last piece of cleanup is
let me just get this on a new line is to
Simply get
is to Simply rename this column so I'm
just going to call this contact name
okay
so we concatenate first name and last
name with the space between them convert
that to uppercase call it concat contact
name
and list it out
one last thing we also want to display
their phone number and we want to sort
by the alphabetical order of the
customer name so let's display phone
number here let's just put in comma
phone number
I think it's just called phone if I'm
not mistaken
yeah
so now we have customer name contact
name phone and we want to order them so
we just put in order by
and here we put in
what was that number customer we want to
order by customer name in alphabetical
order so we can even just put in ASC
here or ascending
to mean increasing alphabetical order
so now you see we have this customer
name Americans souvenirs Automotive
Classics board and toys Cambridge
Collectibles classic gift ideas all of
these are customers in the UK in the USA
we have that contact name listed in
uppercase we have the phone number of
the contact and we have
sorted this list in alphabetical order
that's how you answer SQL queries and
that's all we're going to do over and
over for the rest of the session
essentially
here's another example display a
paginated list of customers sorted by
customer name with a country code column
and the country code is simply the first
three letters in the country name they
should say country code
so the country code is simply the first
three letters in the country name in
lower case
so here's how you can do that
we want to show customer so just
paginated list of customers so let me
just do
let me open a new query here let me do
select star from customers and we want
to show a paginated list so we want to
show where
um sorry we want to limit to let's say
10 customers
so these are 10 customers
then we want to sort them by customer
name so let's do order by
all right it is sorted by customer name
just fine
and then we want to show country code
column
so maybe let's just show
customer number
and customer name
and Country
so now we have customer number name and
Country but we are interested in
something called a country code
and what's a country code the country
code is simply the first three letters
in the country name in lower case so we
want to get the first three letters out
of every country name and that can be
done using this substring function
so instead of country we put in sub
string
country and in substring you specify
where you want to start now in SQL
numbering starts at one not at zero so
just be careful about that and we want
to take three values I think so we just
say
one comma three
and yeah so that gives us just the first
three characters of each country name
and let me just clean that up here so
that gives us the first three characters
from each country name but we are
interested in
we want to make it lower case so we just
type L case here and that's going to
make it lowercase for us and let's just
rename that using as to country code
okay and there you go so now for each
customer name we have a country code
for whatever reason we need the country
code
all right
so that's another function here's one
last function
display the list of the five most
expensive products in the motorcycles
product line with their price rounded to
Dollars and the price is the MSRP column
okay let's try and answer this to the
five most expensive products in the
motorcycles product line
so let's get rid of some of these
okay so let's see select star from
products
there's our products a list of all our
products and here one thing you will see
is a product line so we can we simply
want to look at motorcycles so where
product line
the column product line has the value
motorcycles
okay now we're just looking at
motorcycles here
and we want to check the five most
expensive products
so we let's order them let's order by
MSRP maximum sale retail price I guess
so yeah and we ordered that by MSRP
and we can also just type MSRP should
not be a problem here
okay now they're ordered by MSRP but of
course we want the most expensive so we
type the ESC descending
so now you can see that we have only
motorcycles and we have ordered them in
the decreasing order by MSRP
and
we just want to see the top five
products so I'm just going to add a
limit here so let me just move this down
yeah so let me just add a limit order by
MSRP descending limit five
so now we have the top five products and
maybe we don't need all the columns
mostly we just need let's say the
product code
and product name
and MSRP
all right this is the required
information there is one last condition
here we want to round the price to
dollars maybe we're creating a report
where we don't want to show the full
price we just want to round it to
Dollars and the way you do that is just
type round
so round function will do that for you
so now this number is rounded to Dollars
you also have a ceiling and a floor
function so if you want to round down or
round up you can use those but round
does the job and in round you can also
specify the number of decimal points
that you're interested in for example if
you want to see one decimal point just
specify round one
okay
so that's how you answer this question
five most expensive products in the
motorcycle category
so that was about the mapping functions
you will not
yeah there are a lot more mapping
functions so you generally don't need to
remember all of them although it will
help again for interviews for exercises
and as you solve more exercises you will
automatically start memorizing them but
there are a bunch of different functions
that you can apply to dates and you can
apply to numbers and you can apply to
strings all of them
and one other kind of
function or operation we should look at
is arithmetic you will often have to
combine
data from multiple columns
using arithmetic operations
so here's a question display the product
code product name Buy price sale price
and profit margin percentage
so what's profit margin percentage will
you buy the product or maybe you buy the
parts for that product at a certain
price and then you sell it at a certain
price
the difference is called the profit and
or the margin and the percentage is
basically the sale price MSRP minus the
Buy price multiplied by 100 divided by
the Buy price
okay so that's the profit margin
percentage sale price minus Buy price
divided by Buy price and convert that to
a percentage by multiplying with 100.
for the 10 products with the highest
profit margin so we want to show the 10
products with the highest profit margin
and we also want to round the profit
margin to two decimals so there's a lot
going on here let's go step by step here
first thing is we want to get some
information out of the products table
right so
let's go select star from products
yep so now we select a bunch of products
all right
and what are we interested in product
code product name by price sale price so
let's get product code product name
Buy price
sell price
uh okay is there a sale price I don't
think so there's just an MSRP
yeah
okay so now we have the information that
we're interested in but there is this
last
column that we need which is profit
margin percentage and fortunately I have
the formula here so here's what I can do
I can simply put in the formula here
comma
um
MSRP minus
Buy price
let's get these on different lines
so MSRP minus Buy price
and let's get that down as well yeah so
this is the profit and if you divide
that by Buy price
so these are all column names right so
you you're saying we want to take values
in the MSRP column from them subtract
the values in the Buy price column and
then divide by the values in the Buy
price column
and we want to multiply that by 102 so
let's just put in a multiplied by 100
and let's put the entire thing within a
bracket
okay
so now we have MSR
oh yeah so now we have MSRP minus Buy
price multiplied by 100 divided by Buy
price and let's just call that profit
margin
so let's just rename that so that's our
profit margin and you can see that the
profit margin for this product since we
buy it at 48 dollars and sell it at 95
is 96 percent that is the amount of
money that we've made on top of the Buy
price
and what do we want to do with the
profit margin well we want to
show the 10 products with the highest
profit margin so let's add that so that
will be a sort or an order by
order by and now once we've created this
column we can use it here so we can call
ordered by profit margin
and we want to limit it to 10.
and we want to see the highest profit
margin so we say desc descending limit
10. let's check that
great so now we have this product the
Chevrolet Impala on this product we are
making a huge profit margin we're buying
it for 32 dollars selling it for 80. so
150 percent profit
actually maybe let me just call this
profit margin percent so that it's not
confusing
with the actual number
yep now the last thing we want to do is
round the profit margin to two decimals
and that's easy we just type around here
and another bracket here well I guess we
don't
Let's see we probably don't need that
bracket and we want to round it to two
decimals so there you go now we have the
profit margin rounded to two decimals
and these are the 10 products with the
highest profit margin percentage so
these are the kind of queries that you
should be able to answer by using
arithmetic operations by using sorting
grouping
and aggregation
and mapping functions
you can check out what other operators
are supported in SQL it's not just a
Johan arithmetic you have add subtract
multiplied divide you can divide and you
also have this modulo function which is
to compute the remainder so you can do
that as well and then you have some
bitwise operations and you're already
familiar with comparison operations as
well so comparison operations are
typically used in the where Clause as we
saw with the date
talking about dates SQL also provides
several
functions for extracting information
like the year month Etc out of date
columns so let's look at an example list
the largest single payment done by every
customer in the year 2004 ordered by the
transaction value highest to lowest okay
again seems complex but let's break it
down
we are interested in payments that's
what I can gather here list the largest
single payment so I'm just gonna go here
and first of all just to select star
from payments
okay we have payments now
next
we want
the largest payment by each customer
okay so we want basically the maximum
payment by each customer so we can
probably do a group by customer number
and then for each group of rows for each
customer
we want the maximum payment that they've
done so let's call amount max amount and
let's rename that to
largest
payment okay all right so it's start
starting to make sense now
so we have we select customer number we
select the maximum amount so for each
customer we look at all the payments
we've made and pick the one with the
maximum amount or pick the maximum
amount among those
and of course for that we have to do a
group by customer number
but we want to look at this in the year
2004.
how do we do that well we have a payment
date
and we could check if the payment date
is greater than Jan first 2004 and less
than January 2005 and things like that
or we could simply do where and we could
use this year function so here is all
here is a function just like
other mapping functions and into the
year function pass in payment date
and just check if the year of the
payment date is 2004.
okay
so that's our query right here select
customer number max amount as largest
payment from payments where year of the
payment date is 2004 and group by
customer number
and ordered by transaction value right
so we want to order that by transaction
value so we should also probably put in
order by largest payment
and let's run that
so it turns out that customer number 161
it turns out that customer number 161
made the largest payment in the year
2004 and that payment was
2434 dollars
oh well no
we want to sort it in descending order
yeah so customer number 141 the loyal
customer made 116 000 200 in a single
payment
and that was the highest payment in 2004
by a huge margin actually you had to 84
410 after that
okay
so that's how you pick out information
from a year from a date
here's another example
show the total payments received month
by month for every year
okay this is interesting so
you want to show the total payments
month by month for every year so you
want to see January 2003 February 2003
uh March 2004 and so on
so let's once again start with payments
select start from select start from
payments
we have the data
now we are interested in year and month
so we have a payment date
if we can just create a new column for
ear and a new column for month I think
that should just get us started so I'm
just going to create a new column for
here so I select star which means I
select all the columns but apart from
that I also select year
of payment date
as
payment year
and let's see that so now we have a
payment here over here
and let me just put that at the
beginning
and then we also want the payment month
so we just type month
and we type payment date so from the
payment date we get the month and we
call that payment month
so let's put that on a new line here
comma star so we still want the other
columns or you know what maybe let's
just keep the amounts now or maybe we
don't need the other information
so select payment
date year as payment year month of
payment date as payment month and then
the amount from payments
yep
so now it tells us
for every single payment we now have a
year and a date in the amount but of
course we don't want
of course we don't want uh like this is
still showing us every individual
payment like if I put a comma star here
you will see that we are still looking
at
yeah if I just instead of the amount if
I put star here
okay never mind
yeah so you can see that we're still
looking at every single payment even
though we've created a payment here
column and we have created a payment
month column
we are still looking at every single
payment individually what we want is the
totals for each month and for each year
so how do we do that well
you guessed it we want to total up the
amounts so let's get rid of these other
columns and let's just do a sum
and we want to get the sum of the amount
but of course just doing a sum is not
enough because we also need to do a
group by right because we want to First
Define groups so for each month comma
year we want to get a group of columns
you want to get the group a group of
rows so you want to get all the rows
which were which belong to January of
2003 all the rows which belong to
February of 2003 and then sum up each
group so we type here Group by
Group by and in group by you can
actually provide multiple columns so we
have this payment year column
and we have this payment month column
so now we have a payment here we have a
payment month and we have the total sum
so this is the sum of the amount of all
the payments made in that particular
month of that particular year and maybe
we also want to order by these same
criteria so that we can see it in a more
understandable format so we also order
by payment year and payment month
and you don't need this comma here
so now we have 2003 one and the sum is
26 000 and then 20032 which is February
of 2003 and the sum is 144 000 and then
2003 March is 199
000 and so on
seems like
what is this August September of 2003
was
pretty good so this is how you can now
start doing some basic analysis and
interpretation so this is your Revenue
growth or this this is your Revenue
table so if your boss asks for a month's
wise Revenue table this is what you give
them
but of course you probably don't want to
show these numbers like this like it
doesn't make sense to look at this zero
zero zero zero three here and it's
probably a floating point or a rounding
error somewhere
so let's make this a little prettier and
here again it's a bit difficult to guess
the month from month number going to the
actual month can be a bit difficult so
let's make this a little prettier
now for the above query the query just
that we just looked at let's format the
amount properly with a dollar symbol and
comma separation maybe show it something
like this 26
267.62 and just two two decimal places
and let's also show the month as a
string okay
so now we are
in the territory of printing things
nicely of making things look good so
that's where you need these formatting
functions there are two numbers two
functions one is the format function for
numbers and then the date format
function for dates
so let's first look at the format
function for numbers now instead of
showing the sum just the sum of amount I
am going to call format here
and
I am simply going to put in
I think you can to format you can
mention how many decimal digits you want
so I'm just going to put in 2 here and
format is automatically going to add
commas here
so now you can see that
you have 144 comma three eight four
point three six just by adding this
format keyword here and of course now
it's no longer number nowadays become a
string and let us also rename this
column as Revenue
so now we have revenues one four four
three eight four point three six
maybe let's go a step further let us add
a dollar symbol here how do we add a
dollar symbol well this is a string and
we want to add a dollar symbol at the
beginning of the string
how do we combine two strings that is
done using concatenation so let's call
concat the concat function that we saw
earlier but this time instead of
concatenating two columns we are
concatenating a string the dollar symbol
with the column
so now when we call concat we have
dollar one four four three eight four
point three six
and
that is called the revenue so that's how
we format the numbers
a little other a small cleanup that you
can do here especially if you're sending
it out to somebody this result is maybe
you want to just clean up these call
column names so if you want to just call
it payment year but of course that's
going to be a problem so whenever you
have spaces within column names you can
use these
back codes so this is the code that is
available on your keyboard just below
the Escape key and let's call this
payment month
okay and then let's call this uh Revenue
I think this should be fine just like
this
and once again let's just
changed it here
just cleaning it up a little bit to make
it look nicer
and then you can export it and send it
as a CSV or something
so now you have payment here you have
payment month you have Revenue with
dollars looking good but of course we
still missing this piece we want to show
things like January February Etc here
so if you want to show Jan Feb Etc
here's what we can do we can call date
format so there is this function called
date format
and date format is something you will
most likely have to look up
so date format takes a date as an input
and then it takes a certain format in
which you want to see the date for
example if you want to see the YY mmdd
format then you put something like
percentage y hyphen percentage M hyphen
percentage D or or something and
here are all the variables that you put
in so inside these codes as the second
argument you provide all the variables
that you want to show and based on that
it is going to show you that information
so we are interested in we have a month
here
and we want to show that month
um actually we just want to show the
payment date as a month so I'm going to
remove this month I'm just going to call
date format here
and how do I want to format it let's see
let's see what options we have
so there is this percent B here so I can
take this percent B and if I just take
this person B here
let's see what happens
so you see here now this has become
August and in fact if I want to get the
year name I think the year would be
percent y
so if I want to get the year name I
would maybe just put this
and now you can see August 2003 December
2003 Etc but I just want to keep the
month name here
so now we have the month name so we took
the date called date format on it
directly on the date and we just
extracted out the month using this
person B and that is something that I
looked up in this table there's no way I
can remember all of these so I just have
to look these up each time
and we saw that person B can give us the
abbreviated month name if you want the
full month name then we can use percent
m that can give us the full month name
let's try that too maybe
okay so yeah so now you have the full
month name
but now we've run into a problem because
now we have payment here and we have
payment month but now because we are
ordering by payment here and then
payment month
the ordering the ordering becomes
alphabetical
so we want to display the number we want
to display the string but we want to
order by the number how do we do that
well here's one idea
I create another column
let me just call that let's use month
and payment date so let's get the month
from payment date and let's call this is
called that as month number
and I'm just going to instead of
ordering by
payment year and payment month I'm going
to order by month number
okay
and let's try to run that so that gives
us an error because
now since I have this new column month
number I should also be grouping by this
column otherwise
anything other than
sorry anything other than the
aggregation so here is where we are
doing the aggregation anything other
than the aggregation should show up in
group by so let me just put month number
here
okay so now we have three columns which
we have created we've created created a
payment here that's fine and we have
created a payment month grade and we've
created a month number because we also
want to track uh
we also want to track numbers here
and then we are grouping by payment year
payment month and month number of course
payment month and month number represent
the same information so the same groups
will be formed for every month of every
year we will get a group of rows and
then we are taking the sum of those rows
uh some of those rows to get the sum of
the amount then we are formatting it to
add commas and show two decimals and
then we are adding the dollar symbol and
we are calling that column Revenue
okay so this is looking good this is a
pretty complex query at this point but
it's looking good the only problem I
have is that there is this last month
number column here which I don't like
this is not something I wanna
send to the person who's asking for this
information so how do we remove that so
in some sense we want to use this column
month number for grouping
and for ordering but we don't want to
display it
here's how you can do it it's a very
simple trick here just remove it from
select so you select payment year
payment month payment you select Revenue
but you remove this from here remove the
month number column and just put that
here so just put it in group by
and put it in order by
okay so now we're saying we select year
and we select this payment month which
is nicely formatted and we select this
sum which is nicely formatted as revenue
from payments but in group by we are
grouping by this additional condition
this sort of hidden column which is the
month payment date and we are also
ordering by this additional hidden
column
which is a month payment date
okay and now we finally have
2003 January 2003 February 2003 March
2004 January February March 2005 January
February March okay now this is the
perfectly formatted Revenue column
Revenue table we exported put it into
Excel or send the CSV to whoever needs
it okay
so that's the query there's a lot going
on here so spend your time with it take
go through each step and as I said what
you want to do is you want to start with
the table that seems the simplest
uh just get all the data and keep adding
in
keep embellishing the query step by step
to cover all the requirements and maybe
also just make it look good
so that's all about aggregation and
mapping functions and
arithmetic operators
and dates
so let's talk about combining tables
using joins
a join Clause is used to combine rows
from two or more tables based on a
related column between them
so here for example you have table one
which has three columns and you have
table two which also has three columns
and one of the columns
let's say this is some sort of a
shared column so one of the columns has
is related and has the same or similar
set of values so table one has one two
and table two has one three four
so what you can do is you can combine
the two tables
such that you have this one column and
then for this Row one and then these two
values
you also get the information from this
table these two values and that creates
like a one big row so you can think of
this like the result of the join
so for the
column for the value 1 we get the
information from table one and we get
the information from table two
for the
row with
the value 2 we get the information from
table one
here and there is no information in
table two
so now what happens here whether we put
empty values or we don't show this row
depends on the kind of join
so if it is an outer join then we just
show empty values here for these columns
from table two
and then here there are no more values
left in table one so we go through table
two we pick these values and we just
show empty values here so we show empty
values for three for table for these two
columns from table one and for the
columns from table two we show these
values
and finally we have four for which we
again show empty values from table one
and we show these two values here for
table two okay so that's outer join and
then we have inner join which picks just
the intersection of the values and then
we have the left join and right join so
let's maybe look at some examples and
this will become a lot clearer the first
thing we'll talk about is the inner join
and this is the default join in MySQL so
whenever you type join whenever you're
trying to join two tables on a certain
column then by default it is going to be
an inner join
and let's see it in the context of a
problem and it will make more sense
show the 10 most recent payments with
customer details so name and phone
number
okay so let's go select star from
payments
these are all the payments that have
been made
now the trouble here is that in this
result we only have the customer number
what we'd like to show is the customer
details as well
who is this customer number 471
and we all look at the most recent
payments so let me just grab the most
recent payments
ordered by payment date
or maybe let's do that part at the end
maybe first let's get the customer
details so we have select star from
payments
and we want to show customer details
name and phone number
how do we do that I know that there is a
customer number field in the customer's
table as well so if I do select star
from customers
there is a customer number table
there's a customer number field or
column
so what I really want to do is I want to
fetch the information for customer
number 471 from the customer table how
do I do that I type select star from
payments join
customer number
okay so what did we just do we said that
I want to get some information from the
customer number table as well but how do
I decide which how do I decide which
rows are connected well I want to use
the customer number right so by default
SQL doesn't guess SQL requires you to
provide how you want to match up the
rows of the two different tables so you
say join on on which column you want to
join and then you provide the column
from this table and the column from this
table so you say payments join customer
number on
payments dot so now because there are
two tables involved so that's why you
have to specify the the table name
before you specify the column name
so payments Dot customer number
equals
customers Dot customer number
okay so let's just try and make sense of
this and maybe let's put this on
different lines
so we are saying that I am not happy
with the information that I have from
the payments table I also want to get
information from the customer table I
want to augment some information here
for the customer using the customer
table
and how do I want to augment that
information
I want SQL or my database server to look
at the customer number field
in the payment table here so for this
row look at the customer number field
and find the row
in the customers table
which has the same customer number
so find the row which has the customer
number 471
get all the information from that row
and add it to this row
okay similarly we want
the server to look at the second row and
see that we have customer number 299
here
find the row in the customers table
which has the customer number set to 299
so because we're comparing the customer
number columns
get all the information from that row
and add it here
and let's run that
okay did that lead to an error
let me just check this
um
maybe I have a
maybe I have a typo here somewhere but
yeah
sorry I think I had a typo there but
yeah just repeat select star from
payments join customers so you want to
join payments with customers on the
column customer number and now what SQL
is doing is it looks at a row in
payments it sees a customer number there
and when it sees a customer number from
the payments column it looks for
a row within the customers table with
the same customer number so this
customer number comes from payments and
this customer number comes from
customers and then it takes all the
information for that row and it adds it
to this row
so now we have not just the payment
information but we also have the
customer information attached with each
payment
so that is join
okay now
we probably don't want all the rows here
so that's why we may want to just select
some rows so I'm just going to select
check number payment date amount
um customer number customer name and the
phone number
so I just keep the check number payment
date amount and I just want to keep one
of these columns because these columns
are a bit ambiguous they come from both
so I'll just keep customers Dot customer
number
which I know is going to be equal to
equal to payments.customer numbers and
then I'm just going to keep the customer
name and phone number
okay so now we have check number payment
date amount customer number customer
name phone number
and then we can Now cover the additional
criteria
which is we want to show just the 10
most recent payments so we want to order
by
order by payment date
descending
and limit it to 10.
okay so now we have just 10
now we have just 10
payments the 10 most recent payments and
you can verify this that these are the
most recent payments
six zero nine six zero three five twenty
five and so on
and then we have the amount customer
number customer name and the phone
number okay
now the key thing for you to understand
here is the join how it is how it how it
works it looks at payments looks at the
value of customer number and it picks a
row from customer number which matches
it okay
inner join what does that mean
well
there are several customers
who may not have made
a payment in the last 10 days or who may
not have made a payment at all
so if I remove this for a moment order
by Etc
there are several customers who may not
have made any payments
so I probably don't want to show the
information for those customers who have
not made any payments right now if I do
this inner join here or if I do this
normal
this is the inner join I can also type
inner
then what I'm telling SQL is don't show
me customers for which I don't have any
payment information but if I change this
to Outer join
now we are telling SQL
okay maybe it's like a full
outer join
or let me look up the syntax but if we
change this to a outer join then we
would get information for all the
customers right so we would not only get
information for customers who have made
payments but we would also get
information for customers who have not
made payments and what is going to be
present in the check number payment date
and amount columns empty it's just going
to be empty so just going back here if
table 1 is payments and table 2 is
customers then when you do an inner join
we only look at those rows
where these values are present in both
the columns for for example if customer
number one and two occur in payments and
customer number one three and four occur
in customers then we will only pick one
because that's the common column and
that's what happens when you do an inner
join it just picks the common values on
the other end if you do an outer join
then we're going to pick we're going to
have a row of row for customer one we're
going to have a row for customer two
these two are in payments and we are
going to have a have a row for customer
three and four which don't really show
up in the customers column in the
payments table at all so this is what
it's going to be and there is just going
to be empty data here okay then there is
the left join and right join
so we look at these in a second too okay
but
before we look at left right and outer
joins here are a couple of exercises for
you
show the full office address and phone
number for each employee so once again
you can guess what this will look like
you will say select star from employees
and of course now you want the full
office data so you have an office code
here so you want to do join with offices
on
employees DOT office code equals
offices DOT office code
and maybe let's just put the employee
number here
let's just put employee number and let's
put maybe the last name
first name
and
offices Dot
address
let's just put City right now
offices.city so now you have employee
number last name first name let's maybe
also put office code
so offices DOT office code
okay so now we have employee number last
name first name office code city city
San Francisco and then we also want to
show the full phone number so office has
a phone number so office has a phone
let's check what that is Select
star from
so office has a phone
um so we want to show the offices
offices.phone information as well
so now we have the phone and then every
employee has an extension so we can get
the
EXT column from employee that is the
extension
let's just check that select star from
employees
yeah extension so every every employer
has an extension
so now we have employee number last name
first name office code
we have the phone number we have the
office City
and we have this extension we can
combine these two so we can say concat
let's get that here
so we can say concat and we can
concatenate the office phone with the
extension so now we are concatenating
one column from the offices table and
one column from the employee table
and put those together and let's just
call that
um
employee phone number
or employee phone
okay so now we have the employee number
last name first name office code
and employee phone number maybe let's
just put that here
okay so now we have an employee number
last name first name and then we have
the employee phone number which is a
combination of the phone number from
office and the extension from the
employee
table and then we have the office code
and office City and we've been able to
do this because we've done a join
between employees and offices
okay
and that's what this looks like
here's another example
show the full order information and
product details for the order number one
zero one double zero so here you would
have to look up the order details common
or the order details uh table and then
from the order details table
you would have to join it with the
orders table to get information about
orders and you would have to join it
with the product table to get
information about the product and then
you would simply have to select the data
for a specific order number so here you
are doing two joins or you're joining
three tables so I'll let you figure that
out
it's not too difficult it is just
it is just one more step removed from
what we've done
so that's basic joins and specifically
that's inner joins
now let's talk about left joint right
join and full joints unfortunately in
this data set
there's not enough of an opportunity to
demonstrate all three
so we're just going to look at some
examples online
and specifically I recommend W3 schools
if you're just looking at some SQL
syntax or need some help with SQL they
have pretty good documentation on all of
these
so let's talk about left join okay so
here's how left joint works I'll you can
look at this table and try look at this
picture and try to understand what's
happening
but we have a demo database here so we
have this customers table
and in the customers table we have a
customer ID one two three and then we
have a customer name contact name Etc
you have an orders table so the
customers table will be on the left
the customer's table will be on the left
and the orders table will be on the
right
and what we want to do is we want to
join customers table with the orders
table on the customer ID column
so we say select customers Dot customer
name
comma orders dot order ID so we want to
look at for each customer what are all
the orders they've placed right so we
want to see customer name and we want to
see the order ID
from the customers table
left joined on orders
on customers Dot customer ID equals
order Dot customer ID so we want to just
combine on the customer ID column and we
want to order by
the customer name so let's run this on
you can actually run this online and
check so here's our database we have
three customers and then we have three
orders
of course
and okay actually there's there's more
than that there are a bunch of customers
and a bunch of orders so let's just run
this and let's see the result
okay in our database we have 91
customers and we have 518 orders and not
every customer has placed an order so
when we do a left join between customers
and orders here's what we get
we get a customer name and then we get
the order ID
so it turns out that Alfred
F hasn't hasn't put hasn't created any
order so that's why we have null here
and similarly this person
hasn't created any orders that's why we
have a null here
so for every customer and every order we
could find for every customer and Order
combination we could find where the
orders customer ID matched with the
customers customer ID we have created a
row
and because this is a left join wherever
there were certain customers for whom
there were no orders
there is still a single row that has
been kept
so Alfred has not ordered but we still
have this null here
now if we did not have this left join if
we just had join here and let's run that
you would see that now you no longer
have those null columns so now you no
longer have a customer name so if a
customer does not have a matching order
so if a customer column customer row
does not have a matching order row then
that will be skipped if you're doing a
left join you are telling SQL that you
want to keep all the rows from the left
table which is the customers table and
you don't care about all the rows from
the order table but you do care about
all the rows from the customers table so
even if there is no matching Row from
the orders table just show that customer
name
and then show a null there
okay
so that's left join
then maybe let's look at right join
so here's an example of right join here
we have
orders so we have one table of orders
and then we have one table of employees
okay now
for every order that is placed by a
customer there is also an employee that
is assigned and then we have a table
where we have details of employees
so let's say we want to get for each
order
the names of employees
who is assigned to that order
and let's check it out
so this time we are saying select orders
dot order ID and employee last name
employee first name from orders
and we're saying right join with
employees
so let's run that and let's see what
what happens we are matching on the
employee ID column so we get the order
right we get the order ID
and we are also keeping the employee
last name and first name so we for every
order ID we get the last name and first
name of an employee but of course there
are certain employees who may not have
been assigned any orders maybe certain
employees just don't deal with orders
they are into their managed people
because we have done a right join we are
telling SQL that
you don't want to miss any rows from the
right table from the employees table so
you want to show employees even if they
do not have any matching order columns
so now west Adam West does not have any
orders but we're still showing it here
we're just showing a empty or null value
here instead of course if we did not
have
joint right join here
then you can see
okay let's just do an inner join here
yeah if we just did an inner join which
means we did not do a right join if we
just did an inner join here then
we would only get those employee names
who have valid orders right so just try
to remember this picture where inner
join means that the row must that that
value must exist in both columns in both
tables left join means that all the
values that exist in the left table show
up right join means all the values that
exist in the right table show up an
outer join
a full outer join tells you that you
want to maintain all the rows from the
left left table you want to maintain all
the rows from the right table as well
and you want to fill in nulls wherever
possible so here's an example
we have a customer's table and then we
have an orders table
and
I believe we are doing a full outer join
on customers and
orders and this time you will see that
there are certain
order ID table certain order IDs that
may be null and sometimes a certain
customer name may be null right so
that's how an outer join works so just
keep this picture in mind
this one
outer join means you want to retain all
the values inner join means you want to
retain just the intersection of the
common values left join means you want
to retain all the values from the left
table right join means you want to
retain all the values from the right
table
okay
and one last thing a table can also be
joined with itself you don't have to do
a join between multiple tables and each
instance of the table can be given a
temporary Alias so you need to rename
those tables because otherwise if you're
just joining a table with itself it may
get confusing when you are explaining
which columns to join on so here's an
example remember employees employees
have this reports to
field which reflect refers to another
employee so let's say we want to show a
list of employees with the name and
employee number of their manager
so let's do select star from
employees
okay so now we have all this information
we have employee number
employee last name employee first name
and then a bunch of information and then
we have this thing called reports too so
every employee on most employees except
the president I believe most employees
report to another employee
so now if you want to show who they
report to we want to get information
about who the report to what do we do
well first let me just simplify this
output a little bit let me just put in
employee number
and let me put in last name
and first name
and reports to so that we just have this
information that we really need
okay now I want to take the reports to
number and get information from the
employee table
and insert that information here as new
rows so we say from employees join
employees
but of course and this is an inner joint
of course by default
so first Let's do an inner join and then
we'll see if this needs to be a
different joint
so we say employees join employees and
now this can get confusing because your
both of these are called employees so
let's call up call one of these e so you
just give a space and then type a
temporary name you don't put as here you
just put a space
and
let's call this m so E4 employees and M4
manager
okay so now we are joining and how are
we joining we want to join now this gets
interesting here from E from the first
from the left table we want to look at
reports to
and from the right table M we want to
locate the employee number
so from the employees table we want to
take the reports to information and we
want to find
the corresponding column where the
employee number matches this reports to
a number okay
so think of employees and managers as
different tables they are the same table
but think of them conceptually as
different tables we capture this number
and we get that information from the M
table so that's why we have reports to
equals employee number and let's
grab some information here from the
other side as well so from m
let's grab the first name
and let's just call that
manager first name
and from M let us grab the last name as
well
m dot last name
and let's call that manager last name
and from M let's also grab the
employee number
well actually we have that already we
have reports too
so that's that
there we go
so we have select employee number first
name reports to
and we want to select
okay now reports to let's just put in E
dot because this is going to get
confusing otherwise or SQL and we want
to select m dot first name
and we want to select m dot last name as
manager last name
from the employees table I think I may
have a typo here let me just grab this
okay I think I may have a typo here so
I'm just going to
fix this right now
but yeah so we have e dot employee
number and we have e DOT first name and
we have I see what the issue is because
we have
all these columns in each of the tables
so we just need to add e Dot
so we say
we have an employees table joined with
the employees table one is called E1 is
called M so we have e dot employee
number e dot last name e DOT first name
reports to
m dot first name m dot last name
from employees join employees
on the reports to column joined with the
employee number column okay
so this is probably the most confusing
part of it all so now for every single
employee
who has a manager because this is an
inner join remember so for every single
employee who has a manager we get their
employee we get their manager
information as well so we get the name
and last name of their manager maybe we
can concatenate this so let's maybe just
do
concat m dot first name and m dot last
name
as manager name
so now we have this information about
each employee they we have their last
name first name employee number and then
we have the employee number they report
to and we have the name of the their
manager let's just add a space here as
well
okay now one last thing here that we
would want to just cover is there is a
certain employee the president who does
not report to anyone and we have not
shown that information here because
we are doing an inner join so because
the president Diane Murphy does not
report to anybody
so that row gets skipped but instead if
we do a right sorry if we do a left join
what we're telling SQL is we want to
maintain the list of all the employees
from the left table e
even if they do not have a person that
they report to
so now if you check you have an employee
number one zero zero two Murphy Diane
and for them reports to his null and of
course null value doesn't show up in the
other table so their manager name is
also null
okay so now you see that this is
supposed to be a left join and why this
is supposed to be a left turn left join
and not an inner joint because you want
to show all the employee numbers even if
they don't have a manager
now suppose instead of a left join you
had done a right join what would happen
now
so now we're telling SQL that
only show me employees from the left
table who have a manager
but on the other side on the right side
if there are certain employees
in the M table which do not feature in
the reports to column you should still
show them so let me run that and let me
show you the result so it seems like the
result hasn't changed so one thing that
has happened is Diane Murphy has gone
away but if I scroll down here you will
see that now I have Leslie Jennings
Leslie Thompson Julie farrelli all these
people who do not have any reportees
still show up
this is because we are doing a right
join we are saying that every Row from
the M table should be represented even
if they don't have any matching
information in the e-table so that's the
that's the issue with the right join and
if we did a full outer join
or I think it's just called an outer
join
okay I'm not sure what the
outer join in MySQL is
I guess it's just called full outer join
okay I think I'll have to look it up but
if we did the full outer join then we
would see
this we would see Diane Murphy
and we would also see
all this information
Larry bolt Etc
okay we'll check this out what how do
you create a outer join in MySQL
okay never mind
so that's joins and here are some
exercises for you to try out to become
familiar with SQL joins report the
account representative for each customer
report the total payments for the
Atelier graphic
this is one of the I think this is one
of the customers report the total
payments by date report the products
that have not been sold ever list the
amount paid by each customer and so on
so each of these will require a certain
join not all of them may require joins
and for some of these it's possible that
you can do them without joins in some
cases you will also have to do some
other things like arithmetic operations
etc for example list the names of
products sold at less than 80 percent of
the MSRP
there are two ways to improve query
performance in MySQL especially when
you're working with really large data
sets one is to create an index now if
you often search or order data by a
particular column that's not a primary
key then you can add an index to make
the query performance faster
for example if you search by customers
last name a lot or if you order by
customers last name or not then you
should do this you should run this
command create index customer last name
and give it whatever name you want so
you say create index so and so on the
table customers using the column contact
last name so if we do this if we just
run create index customer last name
index on customers
what we're telling SQL is that we want
SQL to
track the contact last name information
the contact last name column in the
customers table and set up a way for us
to efficiently do queries on that column
so what does this mean well the next
time we do a query on the last name
let's say we do something like this
select star from customers where contact
last name equals Lee because contact
last name has an index this query will
be very fast
if the contact last name did not have an
index then this query would be fairly
slow and the difference would be if the
contact class name did not have an index
then
SQL would have to search through all the
rows but
if the contact last name does have an
index then SQL can actually
avoid searching because it has set up
some ways to
efficiently track information and search
information from the contact last name
column in fact it is using a data
structure called a b tree and you can
see what kind of index is created or
what kind of indexes you have on a table
simply by typing show index from
table name
so you can see that we have the primary
key which is tracked using an index
because typically you extract
information using fine primary key
we have a foreign key so every foreign
key also creates an index but then we
also have this customer last name index
which we just just created
and this index is represented as a b
tree which is a data structure an
efficient data structure
optimized for querying so whenever you
query by last name that is very
efficient
not only querying but ordering by last
name is also efficient so you could do
something like this select start from
customers order by contact last name
limit 10. again if you have an index
this is going to be fairly efficient
if you don't have an index it's going to
be slow it's not going to make a
difference for this database the that we
are working with right now but when you
have a really large data set a really
large database with millions of rows
then this will start to make more sense
so if you are doing some queries and
those queries seem to be taking a long
time maybe consider creating an index or
maybe consider asking the database
administrator to create indexes on the
columns that you are ordering by or
searching by most frequently
okay
and indexes can also be created on
multiple columns if you put conditions
on multiple columns frequently so you
can check that out
then another thing that you can do is
create something called a view so if you
perform a query
or if you perform a query very often or
if you very frequently join tables for
querying
then you can create a virtual table out
of that query and this virtual table is
called a view so here is how a view is
created so we'll see how views created
and how it's used and then you probably
see more learn more about how it works
so to create a view you say create view
USA customers as
you type the name of the view and you
type as and then you type a query like
you normally do so instead of doing
select star from customers where country
equals USA so this is all this is the
information about all the American
customers
what we want to do is we want to take
this query and we want to give it a name
USA customers
so let's say let's say create view USA
customers and that is now going to
represent this query the word USA
customers
how do we use it we use it just like a
normal table now let's say we want to
get just the customers who are in
California
so we can do this select star from USA
customers so now we refer to this view
which we have created
already it's saved in the in the
database that view
so select start from USA customers
customers who are from the USA where
State equals CA
and when we run this
you can now see that we only have
customers from USA of course that's
because this the state is CA but you can
see that USA customers actually used
information
from this query that we had defined
earlier okay so conceptually what's
happening is wherever
the SQL Server sees USA customers it's
simply going to replace this
with this select start from customers
where country equals USA
and in fact you can also run this okay
this is not going to work directly
but yeah uni once you create a view and
use the view so SQL is going to replace
the view name with the actual query that
you have provided
now typically when you create a view no
new data gets created it's simply that
information that is tracked which
queryer viewed
represents but certain relational
databases also support creation of
materialized views so let's say you're
doing joins between certain tables very
often and then you are getting
information about the from that joined
table from that joined uh
query
then you can create a materialized view
which is going to contain the joined
version of the two tables so that
whenever any of those two tables is
updated the view gets recreated and that
is uh like a separate table that is
always tracking the latest version of
the joins of the two tables and that
takes up more space but that makes it
very efficient to query so now whenever
you make queries on that view instead of
re-running the query that creates the
view it it will have the view already as
a table saved within the database
and all that information will be cached
so you can get that you can get the
result out of the view very easily okay
so right now by default
we are not actually creating a table USA
customers but if you make this a
materialized view then
the database is actually going to set up
this
table
call USA customers somewhere and that is
going to be kept up to date with the
list of customers from the USA okay so
that's materialized views not something
you'll have to worry about or work with
often but in case you come across the
term that's what it means
let's talk about executing SQL queries
using python
one way we've seen how to execute SQL
queries is using
the MySQL command line interface another
way we've seen how to execute SQL
queries is using the MySQL workbench and
the Common Thread here is all you need
is to connect to your SQL Server your
database server that could be running
locally that could be running on the
cloud
and once you have connected to that
server you need to be able to send
instructions to the server the queries
that you wanted
that you want to send that you want to
perform and then the database server is
going to give you back the results and
you should be able to understand the
results
so this is something that you can do
from any language every language has
some libraries for working with SQL
relational databases in Python one of
the most popular libraries is the SQL
Alchemy Library
so you can look it up this is
SQL Alchemy or SQL Alchemy and it's a
very powerful toolkit for python that
pretty much everybody who uses SQL
databases and does some programming in
Python
uses this library in fact we use it on
Jovian when
you open your profile page
to get the information for your profile
we use the SQL Alchemy library to get
information out of a mySQL database and
then we display that information to you
on the profile page
okay so it's a very powerful and a very
efficient Library as well it's as it
says here
it provides Enterprise level persistent
patterns designed for efficient and high
performing database access adapted into
a simple pythonic domain language okay
so that's the library we are going to
use
now here's the other thing
there is not just a single relational
database there are many in fact here are
some so MySQL is one that we've looked
at
apart from that there is something
called postgres
so this is sort of a
slightly more advanced version of MySQL
where it also supports
latitudes and longitudes is also
supports like a Json column type it has
more column types
um then there is something called sqlite
so sqlite is a less is a limited version
of MySQL and sqlite is typically used
for situations where you can possibly
you possibly cannot set up a entire
server and you just have to maybe work
with something very light so sqlite
instead of setting up a proper database
server Etc simply uses a file on the
disk and that file just works as a
database of course everybody uses a disk
but sqlite just makes it very efficient
and very fast and very small so
typically this is used in let's say in
in your phones so any Android app or any
IOS app that you use is if it stores any
information on your device typically
that store that information will be
stored in a sqlite
database because it has very low memory
and CPU requirements of course
it is it does not implement the entire
SQL language it only implements parts of
it and
it sort of cuts Corners here and there
to make it possible to use SQL in a very
a low memory setting
in fact in your in your assignment you
will be using sqlite
so that that is something that can run
easily on binder setting up MySQL and
binder is a big challenge so we're just
going to use sqlite apart from that you
have some
proprietary databases like Oracle so
Oracle has its own database again that
has its own flavor of SQL then you have
the Microsoft SQL Server
so that has again its own version of SQL
there are some changes not all the
commands work work exactly the same way
and in fact if you look up any SQL
tutorial they will tell you what the
differences between the different
flavors of SQL are right for example
w3schools is the one that I would
recommend and here on the side you can
see all the possible different
um things that you do that you can do
with SQL and if you open any specific
example here like alter table you will
see how these are different across
different
SQL databases so alter table which is to
change the column name Etc this is how
it works on SQL Server this is how it
works on MySQL this is how it works on
Oracle in this case I think they look
the same there's no change here but
there are other things probably with
constraints where
things would be different yeah so you
see here this is how it works with SQL
Server this is how it works with mySQL
so if you're putting some sort of a
unique constraint in SQL Server you put
it here in MySQL you put it at the end
and so on
so just look things up don't worry about
knowing all the different variants of
SQL
but the way it is relevant for us here
is SQL Alchemy
does not include all of these connectors
to all of the different types of
relational databases so what you'll have
to do is maybe you'll have to use some
kind of a connector a connecting Library
so for example if you are connecting to
mySQL then MySQL python is a commonly
used
connector so you will have to either use
MySQL python or there's another
connector called Pi MySQL so there are
several connectors for MySQL right so
SQL Alchemy gives us the python
interface for writing SQL queries and
then internally it uses one of these
libraries to connect to the specific
kind of database that you want to work
with so you'll need to install both so
now we are going to install SQL Alchemy
and we are going to install Pi MySQL
so let's install both of them
SQL Alchemy handles the python Side by
MySQL handles the MySQL side
and I'm just going to create clear
output here
and let's import so here's how you
connect to a SQL database the first
thing you do is you say from SQL Alchemy
import create engine
so import create engine and create
engine takes a
string a connection string
so what you do is you say create engine
and then you give it this string this
database connection string which
contains all the information required to
connect to the database now remember
MySQL workbench here when we try to
connect to a new database we would have
to provide a hostname we would have to
provide a port we would have to provide
a username and a password so it works
exactly the same way here
we say uh what kind of database we want
to connect to so we want to connect to a
mySQL database so that's why we have
MySQL here
we say what connector we are using now
even for MySQL there are several
connectors that people have written for
SQL Alchemy so we we are using the pi
MySQL connector if we were using the
MySQL python connector then this value
would be different but in any case we
want to use the mySQL database so this
is the kind of database that we are
using plus this is the kind of connector
we are using pi my SQL
then we say colon dot dot and this is
just a standard syntax then we provide
the username
and after the username you provide the
password so
normally you shouldn't type passwords
out but let's say if you wanted to
provide the password directly you would
say
username colon password
then you Pro then you type at
and then you type the server so the host
name that you put here
127.0.0.1 which means the local computer
this is just short for the local
computer is a standard host name
um and that is also known as localhost
so this could be 127.001. this could be
localhost both of those mean connect to
a database on this computer
but if you are connecting to a database
somewhere on the cloud then you should
get the username and the password
and the host name for that cloud
database
next you provide the port so for every
database there are certain Port that you
connect at 3306 is the default Port that
is used in most databases but if there
is a different port then you can ask
your database admin to give you the port
so once again you get the type of
database that you're connecting to the
type of connector you're using colon
slash slash the username password at
localhost colon the port slash
the name of the database that you're
connecting to okay this is not something
you have to remember you can always just
look up
SQL Alchemy
connection string
and let's say you want to look it up for
SQL Server so you can just search
connection string for SQL Server
and you can see what that connection
string will look like so for SQL Server
this is what it will look like my seek
Ms SQL plus pyo DBC so the pyo DBC is
the connector and then username password
add server
so server would be localhost colon 3306
or some other online server slash
database okay
now one thing I've done here is instead
of putting the password
I want I don't want to type my password
into a jupyter notebook
so I have just imported get pass and I'm
going to run get pass I'm going to type
the password Here
so now the variable password contains
the value of the password that I just
typed in but I'm not going to display it
in front of you because I don't want you
to show you I don't want to show you I
don't want you to see my password
so
what I'm then going to do is use string
formatting to insert the password
into this string so now I have the
connection string inside which I have
this Gap using these quotations using
these brackets and then I'm calling dot
format password and that's going to put
the password into that Gap okay
so never put your password directly into
your jupyter notebook especially at work
because that's going to be very bad
because then anybody who has your
jupyter notebook will be able to use
your account always use get pass so just
put the password into a variable and
then
pass that variable using string
formatting into the
connection string and that then creates
this engine
okay so now we've created this engine so
what has happened so far nothing really
it we've just set up this object and
we've given all this information to SQL
Alchemy then we actually connect to the
engine we say with engine.connect as con
c-o-n-n
and then we can execute SQL queries
okay so we connect to the engine as con
and why do we have this width well this
automatically takes care of closing the
connection once we get the result so we
say c o n n dot execute and now I'm
connecting to my local database so make
sure that if you are running this on
your computer you have the SQL Server
MySQL server running and if you're
running this on binder obviously it's
not going to be able to connect to your
local computer so make sure that you're
running this locally on your computer
okay so now we say connection dot
execute and we have a query so we have
select office code comma City comma
phone from offices so let's see what
this query gives us in the SQL workbench
okay maybe first I should do use
database
classic models
or just use classic models
yep and now I can select office code
city phone number so expect to see
information like this seven office codes
and then the city and phone number
so I get the result from con.execute and
let's look at the result the result is
this Legacy cursor result it doesn't
give me much but you can convert that
result into a list
so you just call list on it and that
gives you this list of offices or list
of results and let's check that so here
now you get one San Francisco plus one
six five zero two one nine to Boston
plus one two one five and you can match
that information up here okay
so quick recap
install SQL Alchemy install the
connector import create engine
then create the engine using this
connection string which contains
information about the kind of server the
kind of database you're using the kind
of connector you're using the username
password
hostname and port and database name
of course don't type your password
directly get it using get pass once the
engine is created
connect
like this and then get the result
and now you have this result here so now
once you have this result this is a
python list and it's a list of tuples
the idea I wanted to take away is that
you can create this engine create a
connection and then get data out of a
SQL database using python now of course
this is a lot of work and that is where
you have this nice neat little Library
called IPython SQL probably one of the
most wonderful libraries I've come
across because it takes away so much of
the complexity that you have to take
care of when you're connecting to SQL
databases
so the IPython SQL Library provides
something called Magic commands to write
raw SQL queries in Jupiter so you just
type raw see you just type a SQL query
within Jupiter and that will execute and
that will get you the results and it'll
give you the results in a nice tabular
format something that you can use within
Python and in fact it uses SQL Alchemy
under the hood so you want to have SQL
Alchemy installed and you want to have
the right connector installed so for
example in this case I'm using pi MySQL
so I have SQL Alchemy installed I have
Pi MySQL installed and now I'm going to
install IPython SQL so install the
IPython SQL Library
and now it really is Magic because and
these are called Magic commands the
first thing you do is you have to load
this extension within the jupyter
notebook so you say load EXT so you type
this percentage symbol you type load EXT
and then the extension that we're
loading in is called SQL
and once you type this once you run this
cell low dxt SQL then
you will be able to start using this new
command called SQL so anything that
starts with a percentage is called a
magic command in Jupiter this is no
longer plain python now this is some
instruction that we are sending to
Jupiter
so here's what you can do you can type
percentage SQL
okay and then you give it a connection
string so for example if you give it
MySQL Plus
Pi my SQL
root colon and then you put in the
password here let's say the password is
just password
at localhost
colon 3306 and slash classic models
okay
and I'm just going to reveal my password
here for a second so I'm just going to
the password is well it's akash123 so if
I run this
classic models yeah
so if I run this now I am connected to
the
now I'm connected to them to the
database right I have just typed MySQL
plus pi my SQL colon root so username
slash password so this is a SQL Alchemy
collection string now instead of having
to do import engine create engine etc
etc I can just type colon SQL give it
the connection string
and that is just going to connect to the
to the database now what to do if I
don't want to reveal my password I would
do from a get pass import get pass
and then I would run get pass
and okay maybe I should
put the result into password
okay and then I type my password
so now this variable password has my
password and then I can take this and
just put it into a string so I create a
normal
connections Str I create a normal python
variable and I just insert the password
here so I do dot format
password
and now I've created this connection
string so now I want to instead of
typing out the full connection string I
want to pass the variable connection
string and we do that by in Magic
commands we pass value from variables
using these
brackets
okay so when we type this when when we
have when Jupiter sees this bracket it
says okay
let me take the value of connection Str
which is all of this with the password
replaced here and let me replace this
with that value uh sorry with with all
of this stuff
okay so this is all a roundabout way of
hiding my password but in any case the
the point being
you just provide the connection string
either you type out the entire string
including your password or you put the
connection string into a variable and
you pass it using this bracket but just
with this one line of code we are now
connected to the database
and we can now execute queries and
here's how you execute queries you type
percentage SQL and then you just type
the query like select office code city
phone from offices
so there you go so now you can see that
it's telling me that I'm connected
on using this connection root and it
hides a password thankfully so yeah so
we've typed this query and here is the
result of the query so the result is
office code city phone one two three
four five six seven San Francisco Boston
Etc and the phone numbers
if you have a multi-line query something
that you need to split across multiple
lines then just put a double percentage
and when you put a double percentage
then this entire cell is passed to this
magic command when you put a single
percentage that just works for a line
the double percentage works for an
entire cell
so let's run that
so now here we are doing the same thing
remember for every year and every month
we want to get the total payments so
that's what we have here year month
total payments by as a result of this
complex SQL query percentage percentage
SQL and then you type the name they type
the query
and that's the data
here's when it gets even a more
interesting you can actually combine
python code and SQL code so here's what
I'm doing I'm saying earnings result
equals
and then from this point on once I type
percentage SQL jupyter detects that this
is a magic command and it's going to
read all of this as SQL code okay so
what's happening is that all of this is
being passed into this magic command
percentage SQL and that magic command is
going to under the hood use SQL Alchemy
create a connection using the connection
string that we had set up and pass this
SQL query to that connection and from
that connection get some results and
then take those results and convert that
into this format okay
and then that data frame kind of format
is going to be put into this variable
earnings result so you type the variable
name you type equals and then you type
percent SQL and then you simply type the
query
and now you have earnings result
that was the topic for today as I've
said W3 schools is a good resource and I
would just go through all of these just
to get a sense of everything SQL has to
offer
and use this notebook to learn how all
of these things fit together so we
looked at aggregation grouping
pagination in SQL queries we looked at
mapping functions arithmetic and working
with dates
we looked at how to combine data from
different tables using SQL joins we
looked at improving query performance
with indexes and queues
we looked at how to use Python to
execute SQL queries which is to get SQL
Alchemy get a connector created
connection string pass put the password
into it securely create an engine runs
queries or we could just use the IPython
SQL magic commands and simply
use direct raw SQL statements inside a
jupyter notebook
so what should you do next you should
definitely check out some of these other
challenges on the classic models
database this is from
this professor his name is Richard T
Watson it's a great database and he has
also given you a lot of questions to
solve so there are what about a 100 or
120 questions that you could
um try and solve
so
the more it's all about exercise SQL
there's no other way to become an expert
at SQL and I wouldn't say I am because I
haven't done enough exercises
here's one more set a different database
that you should look at is the
database system Concepts book in on this
book page on dbbook.com you have a bunch
of exercises
so you can check here
Sam sample lab exercises and term
projects so here you can figure out
there is a basic SQL file just like the
classic models database and there are a
bunch of exercises like here are some
Advanced SQL exercises
and this is all based on a university
database so here you have all these
questions the university allows an f
grade to be overridden by any pass grade
create a view that lists information
about all fail grades that have not been
overridden and the view should contain
all attributes from all the tech all the
takes from the takes relation right so
there's a lot
going on here and of course this is more
advanced and then you have some more
basic and intermediate questions as well
right
so these are two good databases the
classic models database and then the
student University database you also
have solutions for the classic models
database so if you want to check out
Solutions this person is very kindly put
up their Solutions so you can look up
the solutions to the different Channel
challenges here
yeah so these are some of the solutions
for the classic models database
try that out then you have these
interview questions with SQL
this is a
this repository has been created by
Alexi grigurev he actually did a webinar
recently a few weeks ago with us webinar
on machine learning but he has created
this repository called data science
interviews and specifically in this
repository you have under technical
questions yeah under technical.md you
have SQL so just check out SQL and here
you have a bunch of questions I think
probably over 50 or 60 Questions and in
you can see some of these get pretty big
but the concepts are the same you see
select order by join and then you're
taking the result of one query and then
using that as a table in another query
and so on
okay so that's SQL for you
yeah I think there are about
what's this 11 questions here but they
cover a lot of different use cases
then w3schools is a great place to learn
SQL Alchemy is again if you want to
learn more about SQL Alchemy the object
relationship mapping here's one tutorial
that I found and went through it seemed
good otherwise reading the official
documentation is always a the best way
in the most comprehensive resource I
wouldn't worry too much about this right
now as long as you can just connect to
databases and make some queries you
should be fine and finally if you really
want to get a book then the this is the
book I would recommend this is the book
so one of the authors is
the professor who I learned SQL under
he was my college professor but yeah
this book overall is still great and
even if you don't want to get the book I
would definitely check out the slides
whenever you want to get deeper into SQL
I would definitely encourage you to
check out the slides on this book for
sure
hello everyone this is Samantha and
welcome to the series solving SQL
interview questions and the series we'll
be covering four SQL interview questions
that were asked at Amazon Netflix Uber
and Google Now before we go ahead and
start solving these SQL interview
questions this is something that I'd
like to introduce you to First and that
is three-step approach for solving any
SQL interview questions generally in an
interview you're not always expected to
give the correct answer but the
interviewer would like to know what is
the approach that you have tried for
solving a particular problem and this is
where a three-step approach might help
you
step one of our approach is
understanding the inputs and the outputs
do not jump into solving the query as
soon as you see the question understand
what are the inputs that you should be
using and what are the outputs that your
final result should be containing step
two articulate Your solution verbally
once you've decided what are the inputs
and the outputs explain your interviewer
what is the approach verbally get a
confirmation of your understanding and
then start writing your query step 3
construct the query step by step once
you've decided what are the inputs and
the outputs once you've gotten a
confirmation of your approach break down
your SQL query into steps and print out
the results of these intermediate
queries and then improve your final
result so now that you've gotten an idea
on how to approach an SQL interview
question let's go ahead and solve one as
you can see on the screen the platform
that we'll be using in the entire series
for solving the interview questions is
known as the strata scratch and if you
look at the screen on the left side you
can see the questions and all the
required information that you need to
know and on the right side you can start
writing the query now make sure that
you're signed into stratascrash.com
before you actually run the code or else
you will not be able to run the code
unfortunately you'll not be able to
check whether the solution is correct or
wrong but we'll be sharing all the
required links for practice and to check
whether your solution is correct or
wrong down in the description so do not
worry much about it in this video we'll
be solving an SQL interview question
asked at Apple as you can see on the
screen the problem that we'll be solving
today is customer details find the
details of each customer regardless of
whether the customer made an order
output the customer's first name last
name in the city along with the order
details you may have duplicate rows in
your results due to a customer ordering
several of the same items sword records
based on the customer's first name and
the order details in ascending order as
you can see we have two tables customers
and orders let me just quickly have a
look at all the columns that are present
in both the tables customer stable
contains ID the first name last name
city which we want and the order stable
contains ID customer ID which I believe
this customer ID is the same as the ID
present in the customers table and Order
date and Order details which again is
something that we want according to our
approach the first step of solving an
interview question is understanding the
inputs and the outputs now what are our
inputs since they said find the details
for each customer regardless of whether
the customer made an order I am going to
use the customer ID as one of the inputs
and they have mentioned what the output
should contain and they've mentioned
that it will contain some duplicates now
they also set to sort records based on
the customer's first name and the order
details so my inputs will also contain
customers first name and Order leaders
to perform the sorting and the output
should contain customers first name last
name and the city along with the order
details so these are going to be my
inputs and the outputs the second step
of our approach is articulating the
solution verbally to the interviewer in
our approach we have established that
the output should contain first name
last name city which is coming from the
customers table and it should also
contain order details which is coming
from the orders table which means we
have to combine both of the table
results to get the final output and for
that I can perform a join now what join
do I have to perform given that I am
joining customers table on the orders
table I'll have to use a left join so
that I'll get all the customer details
present in the customers table
irrespective of whether they've made an
order or not and that's what the
question States so I'll be performing a
left join on the customer's tables with
respect to the orders table to get the
final output result finally they've also
meant mention that we have to order it
by first name
and also order details
so this is going to be my Approach now
the third step of our approach is
constructing the query step by step and
the first part of our query construction
is performing the join select since my
output should contain first name last
name City and the order details these
are the column names that will be
present in the select statement
first name last name
City order details
prom customers
left join
orders
on
customers dot ID is equal to orders dot
cast ID because we have established that
customer ID is the ID that is common and
similar to the ID in the customers table
so let me just run this as you can see
the left join has been performed and
whenever there is a customer who made an
order the order details value is filled
and if that customer has not made any
order that order detail section is empty
now the second part of our query
construction is ordering this by order
details and the customer's first name so
I'm just going to say order by
first name comma order
details and I'm going to run this
as you can see this has been ordered
according to the first name and Then
followed by the order details
so yeah that's what they've been asking
us in the question thank you so much for
watching welcome to the series solving
SQL interview questions in this video
we'll be solving an SQL interview
question asked at LinkedIn
the problem that we are solving today is
salaries differences
write a query that calculates the
difference between the highest salaries
found in the marketing and Engineering
departments output just the absolute
difference in salaries and the tables
that are given to us are DB employee and
DB Department according to our approach
the first step of solving the SQL
question is understanding the inputs and
the outputs for that I quickly just want
to have a look at all the columns that
are present in these two tables so that
I'll know what inputs I have to give to
the table to get the salaries difference
output
as you can see it contains ID first name
last name salary so since they asked us
to calculate the highest difference
between the salaries I'm going to use
the salary column as my input and this
department ID and in the DB Department
table I have ID and the department I
believe this ID is similar to the
department ID present in the employees
table and as they mentioned in the
question they want specifically for
marketing and Engineering departments
department is going to be my other input
what is going to be my output output
just the absolute difference in salaries
so these are my inputs and the outputs
now the second step of our approach is
articulating a solution verbally to the
interviewer as we've discussed that the
columns that we'll be using are salary
and the department
and what they've asked us to calculate
is the highest difference of the
salaries between the Department's
marketing and Engineering so when
they're saying highest you probably are
expected to use the aggregation function
Max in the each department and calculate
the difference between them so my
Approach is probably going to be first
thing I'll perform a join between the DB
employee and DB Department
so that I can get the Department name
and the first thing I'll do is write a
select statement
which will get me the maximum salary
from the Department marketing
and I'll write another select statement
which will get me the maximum salary
from the Department engineering
and then I'll calculate the difference
between this select statement and the
other select statement get the absolute
difference and that's what they're
looking for there's also another way
that you can approach this problem
without having to use two select
statements and that is by using a self
join with the help of table aliases now
right now we are performing a join of DB
employee with DB department so that we
can get the Department name right what
if we know what is the department ID of
the department names marketing and
Engineering we can simply just use this
department ID within this table
calculate the maximum salary of that
particular department and minus it with
the maximum salary of the other
department by performing a self join now
the third step of our approach is
constructing the query step by step in
the first part of our query construction
is calculating the maximum salary for
the Department's marketing and
engineering
so for that I'm just going to say select
Max of salary
from DB employee
join with DB Department
on
DB employee dot Department ID is equal
to DB department DOT
ID I'm going to give the where clause
for the department so that I'll get that
specific Department maximum salary where
DB department is a code
okay so I think I should say
DB department DOT department is equal to
marketing
so let me just execute this
and as you can see INF got the maximum
salary for the Department marketing
similarly I'll also be calculating the
maximum salary of the department
engineering and then I'll get the
absolute difference between these two
select statements
so for that what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put this entire statement
in one bracket
and I'm going to do minus then I'm going
to copy paste the same syntax here
because it's almost the same thing
except for the
marketing name instead I'm going to say
engineering so these are the two select
statements and I'm going to perform
absolute difference between these select
statements so that I will get the
difference between the highest salaries
of the Departments
so I'm going to say
select
absolute
difference of these and I'm going to
give this an Aliyah's name as
salary Tiff
and then I'm going to execute this
as you can see we now have got the
absolute highest salary difference of
the Departments
marketing and engineering
so this is one way of our approach as
we've discussed is another way of
approaching the same problem which is by
using a self join first let me just see
what are the department IDs
for the Department names
marketing and Engineering so I am just
simply going to run this
and as you can see engineering is having
the department id1 and marketing is
having the department id4 so using these
numbers in the department ID column of
the DB employee I will perform a search
join to calculate the highest difference
so for that I am going to say
select
Max of a DOT salary
minus Max of B dot salary
and I'm going to give this as
salary difference
from
DB employee a
and I'm performing the self join here DB
employee B using table aliasis
where
a DOT Department ID which is equal to 1
and
B Dot
Department
ID is equal to 4.
one is for engineering and four is for
marketing and I'm calculating the
maximum salary of the engineering and
maximum salary of the marketing and I'm
performing the difference and since they
said they want the absolute difference
I'm going to say absolute of
this
and then run the score and as you can
see we got the same answers so yeah that
is how you approach these kind of SQL
interview questions thank you so much
for watching in this video we'll be
solving an SQL interview question asked
at Facebook which is a part of meta
let's go ahead and start solving
as you can see on the screen the problem
that we'll be solving today is
popularity percentage
find the popularity percentage for each
user on meta Facebook the popularity
percentage is defined as the total
number of friends the user has divided
by the total number of users on the
platform then converted into percentage
by multiplying by 100.
output each user With their popularity
percentage order records in ascending
order by user ID the user run and user
to column are page of friends so
according to our approach the first step
of our query construction is
understanding the inputs and the outputs
let's go ahead and take a quick look at
the table and we can see that it is user
1 and user 2 and these user run and user
2 columns are paste of friends so we
have to use both user1 and user 2 as our
input columns and the output should be
each user Along With their popularity
percentage now the second step of our
approach is articulating a solution
verbally to the interviewer according to
our approach they've asked us to
calculate the popularity percentage
right which is basically
total number of
friends
a user has
divided by total number of users on the
platform
into hundred
before we actually multiply with 100 and
get the percentage we first need to
figure out how to calculate the total
number of friends a user has and also
the total number of users on the
platform before I figure out what method
or function I need to use to calculate
the total number of friends a user has
or the total number of users I just want
to have a quick look at how the data is
in the table for that I'm just going to
come back here and see
select start from Facebook
I'm going to run this
and as you can see there is user1 and
user 2 where user one two is friends
with user two one and one is friends
with three and four is friends with one
this seems to be a little confusing for
me to calculate a total number of
friends a user has because seems like
one is spread across both the columns
and I can understand that the rest of
the you know users are also spread
across like that so for my better
understanding what I want is if I can
have all the ones on the left side and
their friends on the right side and all
the twos on the left side and their
friends at the right side it is easier
for me to calculate the total number of
friends a user has
and for that
the thing that comes to my head is Union
so Union is basically a method used for
you to combine the results of two select
statements and removes any duplicates
present in it so that's how Union works
so that is going to buy my Approach for
calculating the total number of friends
a user has now the second step is
calculating the total number of users so
if I'm having all the users on the left
side and their friends on the right side
I can just simply say distinct
of user one right that should probably
give me the all existing users on the
platform now the third step of our
approach is constructing the query step
by step and the first part of our query
construction is calculating the total
number of friends a user has let me just
go back to my query editor who write
that query I already have Select Staff
from Facebook friends I'm going to say
Union
it equal to as your one user
I'm going to order this by user run
because they wanted the final result to
be ordered by the user I'm just going to
run this query
as you can see we are now having it in
the format of all the one on the left
side and its friends on the right side
all twos on the left side and it's free
on the right this is how that Union is
working but what exactly is happening
here so when you see the first part of a
query was Select Staff from Facebook
friends right and this is the result
now the second part is we are saying use
user 2 as user 1 and user 1 as user two
so now this column will become user1 and
this column will become as user 2. so
the union basically combines these two
results and removes if there are any
duplicates present there so let's just
see if there are any duplicates or not
as I can see is there any barrage on
Akash no and then we are saying biraj
and himani so there's already a biraj
and himani here so we can remove this
and I'm also looking at Akash and himani
is there any Akash and himani somewhere
here no it's going to stay and there's
also something called as himani and
biraj there's himani and biraj already
here I'm just simply going to exclude
this so it is now in the format right on
how we wanted it which is all the users
on the left side and the respective
friends on the right side now this
explains the first part of our approach
which is calculating the total number of
friends a user has now all I have to do
is just group it by the user one and do
the count of the user too to get how
many friends each user has so the second
step is of our query construction is
calculating a total number of users on
the platform so for that what I can do
is I can just simply calculate the
unique
entry of each user 1 in this table right
all I have to now do is use this as the
input for select
distinct
user one
from this sub query
I'm going to give this stabilizer
thanks
I run this
as you can see now
these are all the distinct users now I
just have to say
and oh
you can see there are a total of nine
distinct users on the platform I just
now have to divide the count of each
user's number of friends by this into
100 to get the popularity percentage but
as you notice here the total number of
users on a platform is using this as the
input for it to calculate the total
number of uses now for me to divide this
by this I have to store this result in
something so that I can use this as the
input for this to calculate the
popularity percentage so for that I'm
going to use a Common Table expression
width is a keyword which indicates that
you're writing a Common Table expression
and I'm going to give this commentable
expression a name with friends as this
let me just
I'm going to remove this
this is my Common Table expression and
I'm going to use this as the input for
my next query which is calculating the
popularity person I'm going to say
select user1 which is basically the one
for each user the popularity percentage
so I'm going to select user one and I'm
going to say
count of user 2 because count of user 2
is the one which will tell you the total
number of friends a user has and I'm
going to divide this by
select
found
distinct
user one because that is the section
which will give us the total number of
users on the platform and this entire
beta is
um the friends
comment table expression
group it by user one because we want it
for each
as you can see
we now have
the popularity now I just simply have to
write this with 100
this is the popularity percentage of
each user
so yeah that is basically how you solve
this popularity percentage question
thank you so much for watching I will
see you guys next time
in this video we'll be covering an SQL
interview question asked at Uber so
let's go ahead and start solving
the problem that we'll be solving today
is distance per dollar
as you can look at the screen you're
given a data set of uber rights with the
traveling distance distance to travel
column and cost monetary cost column for
each ride for each date find the
difference between the distance per
dollar for that date and the average
distance per dollar for that year month
distance per dollar is defined as the
distance traveled divided by the cost of
the right the output should include the
year month and the absolute average
difference in the distance per dollar
absolute value to be rounded to the
second decimal you should also count
both sexes and failed request status as
the distance in the cost values are
populated for all the requests also
assume that all the dates are unique in
the data set order your result by the
earliest request date first so this is
our question and according to our
approach the first step is understanding
the inputs and the outputs so for that
I'm just going back to the question
again and they're saying for each state
find the difference between the distance
per dollar for that rate and the average
distance per dollar for that year month
so I see that they're asking us to
calculate something called as the
distance per dollar per each date so I
see that we have to use a date time
column which I know by looking at the
table it has something called as the
request State so my input is going to be
requested and for calculating the
distance per dollar I need to divide the
distance traveled by the cost of the
right so I'm going to use the columns
distance to travel and monetary cost
so my inputs are going to be these three
request date distance to travel and
monetary cost now my outputs are going
to be as they explicitly mentioned in
the question the output should include
year month and the absolute average
difference in the distance per dollar
and the absolute value to be rounded of
two decimals so now the second step of
our approach is going to be articulating
a solution verbally to the interviewer
which is basically explaining our
approach and getting a confirmation of
our understanding so from the question
we understand that they want us to
include the year and month which means
we are basically expected to extract the
year and month from the daytime column
which is requested so for that I'm going
to use the date format
in this way so that it will extract the
year and month for me
and the second thing they want from us
is the absolute average difference in
the distance per dollar so for actually
calculating the difference first you
need to calculate the average right so
I'm going to use the average window
function so that it is calculated for
each and every row then I'm going to use
the absolute function so that I'll get
the absolute value of the difference
that I'm getting then I'm going to use
the round with 2 as the input because
they've mentioned that they want the
final output to be rounded off to two
decimals then finally I'm going to group
by the year and the month because they
specifically said that they want the
output for each year and month and also
they finally mentioned that order your
results by the earliest request date
first so I'm going to order this by this
date format that we are creating
for year and month
so this is basically going to be my
Approach now the third step of our
approach is constructing the query step
by step and the first part of our query
construction is extracting the year and
month out of the daytime column
so I'm going to say select
date
format
and our column name is request date and
the format that we want is year and
month
sorry and I'm going to give this entire
extracted column a name probably year
month and I'm getting this entire data
from the
request
logs table and since they want this for
each year month I'm going to group by
year month
and I'm going to order by
so this is our code I'm going to execute
now
and as you can see on the screen we can
now see the output for each and every
year and month
now the next step of our query
construction is calculating that
difference between the average distance
per dollar which is absolute value
rounded off to two decimals so for that
as we've established in our explanation
that we'll be using the average window
function so it has partitioned for that
each year and month so I'm going to say
average
distance per
okay I think it's distance to
travel
divided by
morning 30 cost so they have mentioned
in a question that uh the distance for
calculating the distance per dollar it
is distance to travel divided by the
cost so I've given that now I'm going to
minus this by average of
distance to
travel
divided by monetary
cost
over
Partition by since they want this to be
partitioned by the year end month which
is our
date
format
request State
of
this
year month
so the reason why we are using this year
month column directly instead of giving
it a column name which is year month
window function will not be able to
identify this prior so we need to
specify the entire thing
so this is done now I'm going to give
this entire column name of function
which is probably called as the
average
difference
so this entire thing is again coming
from the Uber request logs and order by
human Group by your month so I'm simply
going to run this query now
as you can see
it you now have
the year month and the average
difference but in the question that
specified that they want it explicitly
as the absolute value right so you now
have to use the absolute function and
that's what I'm going to do now
so I'm going to say absolute value
of this entire
thing
and I'm going to run it
differences
as you can see this has been rounded off
to absolute value which is basically
it's returning your positive value now
they also want this to be rounded off to
two decimals so I'm now also going to
use
round method
so I'm going to say
round and then I'm going to come back
here
and say two
and then I'm going to run the code
as you can see now this is rounded off
to two decimals so that's basically what
they're looking for the output should
contain the year month and the average
difference between the distance per
dollar the absolute value rounded off to
two decimals
so yeah that's how you solve these kind
of SQL interview questions thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys next
time bye in this video we'll be covering
an SQL interview question asked at
Amazon so let's go ahead and start
solving
the problem that we'll be solving today
is monthly percentage difference given a
table of purchases by date calculate the
month over month percentage change in
Revenue the output should include the
year month date in this particular
format and percentage change rounded to
the second decimal point and sorted from
the beginning of the year to the end of
the year
the percentage change column will be
populated from the second month forward
and can be calculated as this month's
Revenue minus last month's Revenue
divided by last month's Revenue in 200.
so they're also giving an idea on how to
calculate this percentage change column
according to our approach the first step
is to understand the inputs and the
outputs and we can do that by reading
the question clearly once again
since they're saying given a table of
purchases by date calculate month over
month percentage change in Revenue there
is some day time column involved here so
for me to confirm whether we have a date
time column or not I need to have a
closer look at all the columns in the
table so if I scroll down I can see all
the available columns in that particular
table which is named as the SF
transaction so I see ID created at Value
purchase ID so my input is going to be
the date time column which is created at
and since they are wanting the
percentage change in the revenue I'm
guessing the value is the one which
contains the revenue number so my inputs
are going to be created at Value and
they say the output should include the
month year date and percentage change
so my output are simply going to be that
month year column and also the
percentage change column that will be
calculating using the formula that they
have mentioned in the question
so the second step of our approach is
articulating a solution verbally to the
interviewer which is basically
explaining our approach and getting a
confirmation of our understanding
specified in our question the output
should contain the daytime column in a
particular format which is basically in
the year and month I'm going to use the
date format function in MySQL which will
help me extract the year and also the
month
for that particular output column and
they are also asking us to calculate the
percentage change in the revenue before
we calculate the percentage change in
the revenue we first need to calculate
the revenue right and for that I'm going
to use the sum for the entire value
column and group it by the month and
year column that we are extracting so
that we can get the month wise Revenue
and this will generate the revenue for
us
so once the revenue is generated I am
going to now calculate the percentage
change in the revenue using the formula
described in the question so in that
question they are using the terms such
as previous month and current month and
one function that comes to my head for
calculating the percentage change is the
lag which is a window function and I'm
going to use the lag for that
now they've also explicitly mentioned
that they want us to round off the
entire percentage change to two decimal
points and for that I'm going to use the
round function with the input as 2 so
that the decimal points are rounded off
at 2. and finally they want us to order
this as per the starting year so I'm
going to order it by the month year
column that we are generating so this is
basically going to be my Approach
now the third step of our approach is
constructing the query step by step the
first step of our query was extracting
the month and the Year from the date
time column using the date format
function
so select date format
from the created add column it has to be
in the format percentage y percentage m
and I'm going to give this column a name
as your month
and this data is coming from SF
transactions
so I'm going to now run the query
as you can see on the screen we have
extracted the year and month column
using the date format now the second
step is calculating the total revenue so
for that I'm just going to check
sum of
value
and give this a revenue name
and I'm going to
group it
by
this column year one so that I get the
monthly Revenue
so I'm now going to run the query again
as you can see in the output we now have
the monthly Revenue
now our next step in constructing our
query is calculating the percentage
change in the revenue using the lag
window function and we are going to use
the formula that has been described in
the question
so as described in the question I am
going to first use the formula this
month's Revenue minus last month's
Revenue which is for this month's
Revenue I'm simply just going to say sum
of value and for last month's revenue is
where I'm going to use lag of
sum of value
okay
and since this is a window function to
indicate the SQL that this is a window
function I'm going to use the over class
and I'm going to put this entire thing
in Brackets and divide this entire thing
Pi last month's Revenue again which is
where I'm going to use the lag sum of
value and I'm going to indicate that
this is a window function and I'm going
to multiply this with 100 I'm going to
give this column a name percentage
Revenue
I'm going to run this
as you can see the output now we have
the year month revenue and percentage
Revenue now this next step is rounding
up this entire thing to two decimals so
I'm now going to use round
function
and then
commit by 2 and then going to run this
code again
and you should be able to see that this
is now rounded off into two decimals now
the last step that we need to do is
basically ordering this by the year
month I'm now just simply going to say
order by
year month
and then I'm going to run
and you can see that again this has been
ordered
so this is our output
since our question says that the output
should only include the Year date month
and the percentage change I no longer
need to show this Revenue column so I'm
just simply going to remove this
or you just simply have
the ear and the percentage Revenue
so yeah that's how you approach this
particular SQL problem thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys next time
hello everyone welcome back to the
series solving SQL interview questions
in our last video we've sold an SQL
interview question asked at Google using
our three-step approach in this video
we'll be solving an SQL interview
question asked at Netflix so let's go
ahead and start solving as on the screen
the problem that we'll be solving today
is top percentile fraud on the same
platform status crash that we'll be
using throughout this series let's take
a look at the question now ABC Corp is a
mid-sized insurer in the U.S and in the
recent past the fraudulent claims have
increased significantly for their
personal auto insurance portfolio they
have developed a ml based predictive
model to identify propensity of
fraudulent claims now they assign highly
experienced claim adjusters for top five
percentile of claims identified by the
model your objective is to identify the
top five percentile of claims for each
state your output should be policy
number state claim cost and fraud score
but before we get into that I'm seeing
terms such as person type so what
exactly does this percentile mean
percentile is simply a value under which
a percentage of data falls into so if
you look at the screen we have data
points such as 40 50 60 so on total 10
data points and we are being asked to
calculate the 30th percentile so the
first step of calculating a percentile
is arranging the data points in
ascending order that is from lowest to
the highest the next step of calculating
that particular value under which 30
percent of the data Falls is you have to
count the numbers from left to right
482 is the number under which 30 percent
of the data falls into now coming back
to our question where they asked us to
identify the top five percentile what
they meant is basically finding all the
values that fall under the top five
percent of the fraudulent claims the
first step of our solution is
identifying the inputs and the outputs
so let me take a look at all the columns
that are present in the table to see
which will give me the
fraud claim so I can see that there's a
column called as frog score so I'm going
to use this as the input for calculating
the fraud claim and since they're saying
that they want it for each state I'm
going to use the column called as state
as mentioned here so my inputs are going
to be fraud score and State
what are my outputs going to be here
they explicitly mentioned that it should
contain policy number state claim cost
and fraud score now the second step of
our approach is articulating a solution
verbally which is basically explaining
your approach to your interviewer and
getting a confirmation so in our
questions since they are asking us to
identify the top five percentile of
claims from each state the thing that
comes to my head for calculating the
percentile is a window function end tile
which will help you calculate percentile
squat tiles Etc so my input for the
entire function is going to be 100 so
that it divides the entire data into 100
equal parts which is what percentile is
and then I'm going to use a filtering
technique for filtering out the top five
percentage now when they said from each
state I am using a window function here
right and in window function you have a
clause called as Partition by which will
help you create Windows as per the
column that you mentioned in it and
since the question says from each state
I'm going to say Partition by each state
in my window function so that for each
state I'm going to get the top five
percentile now the third step of our
approach is constructing the query step
by step I'm going to say select star
since they want almost all the columns
in the output and tile is the function
that I'm using to calculate the
percentile with the input as 100 so that
the data is divided into 100 equal parts
I'm going to use the over class used to
indicate that you're using a window
function and I want each of this Windows
to be partitioned by State since the
question States they wanted from each
state then I'm going to order this by
fraud score the column which contains
the fraudulent claims
and since they want top five percent I'm
going to order this by descending order
and I'm going to give this entire entire
function column a name which is
percentile since that's what we are
calculating and this entire data is
coming from the
so I'm running it okay great I now can
see that it is ordered by the fraud
score and divided into 100 equal parts
now the next step is for me to
filter out the top five percentile from
this entire query so this table has to
be an input for another table so that I
can filter it out using the where Clause
so that's what I'm going to do now this
table is going to be
one and I'm going to
select star
from this table
I'm going to give this table a name
called as
percentile table and filter out where
percentile is less than or equal to 5
because we are looking for the top five
percentile
so I'm going to run this query now
and there you go you now have as stated
it should contain policy numbers state
claim cost fraud score percentile and
then you're containing top five
percentile for the each state since they
said the output should only contain
these and you don't want it to show the
percentile you can explicitly mention
here what are the column names that
you're looking for so I can simply say
policy num
state
claim cost comma
fraud score
from this table and then I'm going to
run it so there you go policy number
state so these are the top five
percentiles of fraud cases from each
state here that's how you go ahead and
solve this particular kind of questions
we will see you guys next time bye let's
take a look at the question now find IDs
of companies that have more than two
users who speak English German French or
Spanish
so according to our approach our first
step is to understand the inputs and the
outputs clearly now for me to understand
the inputs clearly I need to know what
are the columns present in the table
Playbook users if you scroll down you
will see the inputs that are given to
you which is user ID created at Company
ID language activated it and state now
among these what should be my inputs and
how will I know that by reading the
question clearly which is find IDs of
the companies so I need to use the
company ID that have more than two users
so when they are talking about users
which means I'll also have to use user
ID who speak English German French and
Spanish so I don't see any columns with
respect to this but I can see that there
is a column known as language so I now
need to filter out these languages from
the column language so what are my
inputs Company ID user ID and the
language Now what are my outputs since
the questions only simply States find
the IDS of the companies my output will
only Simply Be Company ID so my inputs
are Company ID user ID language and my
output is only simply Company ID now
step two of our approach is explain your
approach verbally now that you've
understood what are the inputs and the
outputs you now have to explain to your
interviewer what is the approach
if you look at the question it says find
the IDS of the company so they want you
to find for each company which means you
have to use a group by Clause known as
Company ID and then since they're
talking about that have more than two
users they want to perform some
aggregation function in this case which
is count so you're going to have to
perform an aggregation function count
for finding out more than two users
and since they want it for each company
you'll have to do something called as
Group by for each company who speak XYZ
languages so you now need to filter out
these languages from the column language
so one operator that comes to my mind as
soon as I'm checking for a string value
is in so I'm going to check whether this
particular language is present in the
language column or not for that
particular user now that I've explained
my approach to my interviewer verbally
the third step is basically constructing
my query step by step and that's what
I'm going to do now the first step of
constructing my query is filtering out
the users who are speaking the languages
x y z
select
since my output should only contain
Company ID I'm only going to give
Company ID from the
table Playbook users
where
language in
I'm going to give
English
German
French and Spanish
so I'm just going to turn this code okay
now it's showing me all the company IDs
where these languages are presenting but
since I want for each Company ID I'm
going to do Guru by
company
ID
great now the classes they want the
users who are more than two in number
this is where I'm going to use my having
Clause having
count or user ID greater than two and
now a company might contain like
multiple entries I want distinct user ID
unique user ID I'm going to say since
this side it has to have more than two
I'm saying greater than 2 and then
executing my query
and it says there is some error which
says having count oh seems like I have a
typo here so I'm going to say distinct
and then I'm going to run my code and
there you go so these are the companies
where there are more than two users who
speak the languages English German
French and Spanish so this is how you
approach in solving an SQL query so keep
three things in mind which is basically
understanding your inputs and outputs
explaining your approach verbally third
thing is constructing your query step by
step that's it for this video guys I
will see you next time bye will you
[Music]
come back